[Musique]
bonjour à tous il est 15h c'est le
retour de ce Grand Direct autour de la
réforme des retraites que vous suivez
sur l'antenne depuis Xena depuis
maintenant huit jours nous sommes au
lendemain effectivement du vote autour
de l'article 7 sur le décalage de l'âge
de départ à la retraite et au lendemain
de cette adoption le Sénat a attaqué la
suite des articles car il faut aller
vite si les sénateurs veulent finir
l'examen des 20 articles au total d'ici
dimanche minuit pour m'accompagner toute
cette après-midi ce grand direct on
retrouve alexandre Poussin en tribune de
presse bonjour à vous Alexandre bonjour
Quentin quelle est ma compagnie
effectivement aujourd'hui vous avez
suivi attentivement tous les débats de
ce matin que contient l'article 8 et
bien Quentin cet article 8 de la réforme
des retraites il est très important car
il concerne les départs anticipés à la
retraite avec notamment des mesures pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
tous ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
avant 20 ans pourront partir avant cet
âge légal de départ qui a été reporté à
64 ans avec différentes bornes de d'âge
en fonction des durées de carrière des
personnes concernées à cette réforme des
retraites elle prévoit également des
parents anticipées pour les travailleurs
handicapés qui pourront toujours partir
à 50/50 alors que vos modifiez la
majorité de droite et du centre du Sénat
dans cette article 8 elle est sénateurs
ils sont plutôt favorables les sénateurs
de la droite sénatoriale mais ils
veulent maintenir un départ anticipé à
60 ans pour les travailleurs déclarés en
incapacité permanente et puis la
majorité des droits de sénatoriales et
également très attachée à un amendement
qui va être discuté cet après-midi et
qui prévoit une surcote des pensions de
retraite des maires de famille sur les
trimestres cotisés à partir de 63 ans
donc voilà ça c'est vraiment
l'amendement qui va être discuté cet
après-midi Alexandre on sait que depuis
deux jours maintenant les débats sont
très vifs entre la droite et la gauche
il y a toujours de fortes tensions dans
l'hémicycle où on s'accuse mutuellement
de ne pas vouloir débattre sur le fond
c'est encore le cas autour de article 8
n'est-ce pas effectivement ça a été très
tendu ce matin elle est débats ont
commencé sur les chapeaux de roue car
les sénateurs devaient examiner
l'amendement de Bruno Retailleau le
président du groupe les républicains au
Sénat qui propose et bien d'accélérer la
suppression de certains régimes spéciaux
de retraite une suppression qui est
prévue par cette réforme des retraites
écoute théâtre ce matin la droite
sénatoriale a annoncé vouloir reporter
l'examen de cet amendement à plus tard
dans ce texte de la réforme des
retraites alors la gauche sénatoriale a
crié au refus de débattre de la part des
sénateurs de droite et puis de son côté
Bruno Retailleau à accusé à la gauche
d'alimenter un climat social tendu alors
qu'il y a également des actions
d'opposants à cette réforme des coupures
d'électricité qui touchent des
établissements de santé notamment et
puis des permanences d'élus et puis une
fois que l'examen de cet amendement a
été reporté les débats ont continué
c'était plutôt calme jusqu'à l'arrivée à
ce fameux article 8 la gauche avait
préparé des centaines d'amendements de
suppression de cet article 8 et la
droite sénatoriale à souhaiter accélérer
les débats pour arriver à directement au
débat sur l'amendement du rapporteur LR
René Paul Savary qui prévoit à cette
surcote des pensions de retraite des
maires de famille et si jamais cette
amendement est adopté que l'article 8
est rectifié et bien ça pourrait faire
tomber de nombreux amendements de la
gauche et bien justement c'est René Paul
Savary qui s'exprime en ce moment dans
l'hémicycle le retour au direct dans les
débats une surcote de 5% sur le plan du
montant est effectivement équivalent à
une année de retraite puisque la surcote
porte sur un
une disposition actuelle qui fait qu'on
estime qu'une durée moyenne de retraite
étant de 20 ans quand vous avez 5% de
façon complémentaire vous avez les 100%
autour de 20 ans ça correspond à une
année de départ anticipé sauf sauf que
il y a d'un côté ces 5% qui sont viager
répartis 20 ans ce qui est déjà signifié
que de l'autre côté vous Perrier
directement ça veut dire que vous en
prenant de façon anticiper la carrière
vous avez un coût qui tombe directement
sur le sur le système de retraite que
cette mesure qu'on leur dit insuffisante
et oui je partage c'est jamais suffisant
peut-être que on peut éventuellement
l'élargir et ça a été proposé à travers
un amendement l'élargir jusque 30 62 ans
non à 62 ans dans le régime actuel vous
n'avez pas de surcote puisque pour effet
aller la surcote il faut aller non
seulement avoir son taux plein mais
aller au-delà de l'âge légal donc on
peut avoir une surcote dans le régime
actuel à partir de 62 ans et un
trimestre qui correspond à 1,25 % de
surcotte que vous avez tout au long de
votre carrière et là jusque trois quatre
trimestres nous avons contingenté la
mesure à 4 trimestres de façon à ce que
le coût soit raisonnable mais si
monsieur le ministre vous souhaitez
qu'on aille un peu plus loin pour rester
dans le droit et gagner encore donc
trois trimestres ne vous gênez pas pour
donner un avis favorable parce que à ce
moment-là on dépassera le droit actuel
donc il me faut votre autorisation et
franchement je préférerais qu'on fasse
un effort pour les maires de famille
plutôt que par des mesures d'âge qui
ratent leur cible mais on aura
l'occasion d'en discuter tout à l'heure
c'est un avis strictement personnel que
je me permets de vous dire en tout cas
notre mesure pas suffisante touchera
néanmoins 30% des femmes d'une
génération 30% des femmes d'une
génération qui liquide une génération
par rapport au nombre de femmes qui
liquide leur retraite sur une génération
ça me paraît significatif ça coûte
touche quand même 130 000 personnes donc
c'est un dispositif qui mérite toute
votre attention et qui compte tenu des
explications que je voudrais donner que
j'espère le plus clair possible nous
permet de vous proposer de prendre cette
mesure et pas les autres que les sont
traduites à travers vos sous amendements
parce que c'est celle qui correspond le
plus au aux préoccupations de nos maires
de famille et qui conduisent je le
répète une fois encore mais des fois on
peut être répétitif dans ce débat à une
diminution des niveaux de pension entre
les hommes et les femmes je vous
remercie merci la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente je
me suis exprimé longuement à la fin de
la discussion générale sur l'article
donc comme je l'avais promis je vais
être bref le gouvernement soutient
l'amendement adopté par la commission
des affaires sociales parce qu'il a ce
double mérite à la fin de permettre le
maintien d'un avantage de temps sous
forme de majoration durée de
d'affiliation régime pour les femmes et
plus largement les assurés bénéficiant
de trimestres dit familiaux qui n'ont
pas une carrière complète au moment de
l'âge d'ouverture des droits et parce
qu'il permet une surcote pour celles qui
au contraire ont atteint la durée
d'affiliation requise à 63 ans et alors
qu'il restera quatre trimestres à
travailler donc c'est un avis favorable
c'est un avis défavorable pour les mêmes
raisons que c'est l'évoquée par monsieur
le rapporteur y compris les questions
des équilibre budgétaires pour
l'ensemble des sous amendements je fais
juste une parenthèse pour dire que un
certain nombre d'interventions ont
souligné la difficulté qui subsiste
quand elle est à la différence de niveau
de pension entre les hommes et les
femmes c'est évidemment à la fois un
constat et un regret qui sont partagés
mais la réalité de la solution pour que
les pensions des hommes et les pensions
des femmes sont identiques ne tient pas
au système de retraite mais bien
l'égalité professionnelle et à la
résorption des inégalités tout au long
de la vie c'est un sacré chantier ça me
permettait cette familiarité et qui
dépasse très largement le cadre de ce
projet de loi donc défavorable sur tous
les amendements et favorable au 21 27 de
Monsieur Savary
merci alors pour explication de vote
mais présidente rossignol
d'accord mais
oui Vivi on va faire on va faire
globalement voilà merci madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup alors je vais
faire un explication de votre sur
l'amendement ça varie avant j'inverse un
peu d'abord pour dire une chose c'est
que cet amendement c'est l'ambulance qui
suit l'offensif terrestre contre la
retraite à 62 ans et que bien entendu
comme on est respecte que des
conventions on ne va pas tirer sur
l'ambulance c'est pour ça que nous
voterons cet amendement enfin en ce qui
me concerne je voterai pour autant j'ai
quelques remarques à faire sur cet
amendement la première concerne un peu
les sous amendements monsieur rapporteur
on pourrait faire et les majorations de
durée d'assurance et l'augmentation de
et la surcote là n'est pas
contradictoire de l'autre quand on a 35%
des cas de rémunération entre les femmes
et les hommes on pourrait aussi
augmenter spécifiquement les pensions
des femmes
première remarque deuxième remarque ça
concerne la nature des écarts de salaire
entre les écarts de pension entre les
hommes et les femmes il y a deux
facteurs premiers facteurs c'est
effectivement les carrières trouées
deuxième facteur c'est la faiblesse des
rémunérations des femmes pendant toute
leur durée d'activité qui impactent
aussi leur montant de pension et de ce
point de vue là votre amendement qui est
spécifiquement réservé aux maires de
famille
fait l'impasse sur les inégalités
salariales sur le fait que il n'y a pas
que les maires de famille
malheureusement qui souffrent de
rémunération insuffisante et
inégalitaire les femmes qui n'ont pas
d'enfants sont dans la même situation
l'écart résiduel de rémunération entre
les femmes et les hommes et de 9%
indépendamment des carrières celui qui
reste apost égal travailler égal diplôme
égal donc en excluant toutes les femmes
qui ne sont pas mère de famille de cet
amendement vous ne répondez pas à
l'écart de rémunération spécifique entre
les femmes et les hommes qui impactent
également la carrière des femmes qui ne
sont pas mère de famille enfin je ne
crois pas seulement cette mesure est
utile mais je j'ai un doute sur sa
dimension nataliste pour tout vous dire
je connais pas une jeune femme qui a
28,30 ans se demande si au moment où
elle veut le mettre un bébé en route
elles auront ou non une surcote ce
qu'elles veulent savoir c'est c'est
pourront travailler élever leurs enfants
avoir un logement
avoir une crèche et ne pas souffrir dans
leur carrière du fait d'être mère de
famille merci la parole est à Madame A
poursu poli
ah d'accord ok merci
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues j'ai eu à au moins à deux
reprises l'occasion de m'exprimer par
rapport à cet amendement en réalité et à
la logique politique qu'il suit à la
fois quand j'ai présenté pour mon groupe
la motion référendaire et encore et
encore hier en fait ce qui n'est pas
juste et nous l'avons dit à plusieurs
reprises c'est le fait d'allonger le
l'âge de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
qui pénalisent plus particulièrement les
femmes toutes les femmes qu'elles soient
mère de famille ou pas mère de famille
les explications vous les a donné par
rapport aux carrières hachées par
rapport aux inégalités salariales mais
vous n'avez pas voulu les entendre que
ce soit aux banc du gouvernement ou
au niveau de nos de notre rapporteur
nous avons eu également nous nous avions
fait un amendement global pour réécrire
cette cette amendement finalement il a
été il a été rejeté donc vous en rien la
problématique des femmes qui ont des
petites des carrières hachées des petits
des petits salaires et qui vont être
pénalisés par cette elles sont les
grandes perdantes je les dis encore hier
lors de la question d'actualité même si
le ministre essaye de démontrer le
contraire alors en réalité évidemment
comme nos collègues socialistes comme
c'est un petit plus c'est un petit mieux
pour quelques femmes cet amendement on
va le voter mais c'est vraiment
totalement insuffisant et ça ne répond
pas à la demande des femmes et puis moi
je voudrais vous donner la proposition
des communistes qui régleraient cette
question de surcote nous vous le montant
du congé parental d'éducation en fait on
est pour qu'il soit équivalent à 100% du
salaire ce qui éviterait justement la
question de la surcote il ne me dites
pas que vous n'avez pas l'argent on a
plein de solutions pour financer ces
mesures mais vous les refusez alors en
attendant que vous réfléchissiez et bien
on va voter ce petit pas très petit mais
faut commencer par quelque chose merci
beaucoup madame ponce
oui merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais dire monsieur le ministre
que tout à l'heure il a dit quelque
chose et il a raison il a dit
l'effacement enfin la neutralisation des
trimestres enfants n'est pas que due à
l'allongement d'âge il est dû aussi au
fait que les femmes travaillent plus
c'est l'effet générationnels les faits
noria il a raison à deux tiers un tiers
parce que un tiers effectivement des
trimestres ont été effacés par la loi
2010 pour 2017 ça va être encore plus
important je pense nous vous l'avons dit
120000 femmes par génération aujourd'hui
partent à 62 ans et de toute façon font
ce choix elles ont donc les deux
conditions elles le et elles partent à
taux plein donc cette trimestre des
trimestres enfants vont tous là devenir
des trimestres travaillés monsieur le
rapporteur la surcote effectivement vous
l'avez dit c'est une neutralité
actuelle mais l'esprit de la surcote
c'est le volontariat
aujourd'hui pour ces femmes si vous
voulez à 62 ans elle pouvait travailler
encore deux ans et on l'a dit elles
auraient eu 10% 10% de surcotte 10% de
surcotte c'est parce qu'effectivement
leur patrimoine retraite c'était neutre
sur leur patrimoine retraite c'est à
dire que les deux ans qu'elle n'avaient
pas elles ne gagnerait par la surcotte
aujourd'hui vous leur donnez la moitié
je parle des 120000 femmes en leur en
donnant la moitié vous faites baisser le
patrimoine retraite de ces femmes de ces
femmes qui utilisaient majoritairement
leur trimestre d'enfants nous vous
l'avons dit les mesures d'âge sont anti
redistributives elles accroisse les
inégalités
toutefois et vous préférez ça
effectivement au départ parce que
effectivement vous voulez qu'on produise
plus et vous voulez surtout respecter le
pack de stabilité à court terme et vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur c'est
pas pareil en termes de termes de court
terme donc c'est pour ça que vous
préférez la surcote donc tout comme mes
collègues comme ça limite c'est une
mesure une des mesures de tes nations de
la brutalité de la réforme bien entendu
nous la voterons avec tout toutes ces
considérations
merci madame la Présidente oui
effectivement cette amendement c'est une
petite mesure de compensation que vous
avez négocié mais qui ne va pas annuler
la brutalité de cette loi vous avez au
moins le mérite de la cohérence avec cet
article 8 parce que dans la casse de
notre service de notre système de
solidarité avec cette volonté que vous
avez de faire travailler plus deux ans
de plus nos concitoyens quel que soit
leur difficulté et la durée de leur
carrière il y aura peut-être d'autres
mesures de compensation votées mais
quand même
vouloir au départ faire travailler deux
ans de plus des travailleurs qui sont
déclarés inapte au travail les
allocataires de lâche les accolocataires
de la location de cessation anticipées
d'activité les travailleurs ayant une
carrière longue les travailleurs
handicapés les travailleurs qui ont une
incapacité permanente à la suite d'un
accident de travail ou une maladie
professionnelle les fonctionnaires
handicapés les fonctionnaires enfin je
ne vais pas en rajouter on est vraiment
là dans cette volonté un moment donné
dans celui brutalité de faire travailler
plus les personnes les plus fragiles et
les plus précaires bon bien évidemment
les femmes ont la tous dit ici sont les
grandes perdantes de cela et je le redis
ce n'est pas cette petite mesure qui va
améliorer leur retraite ce que je
voulais dire quand même en accord avec
mes collègues c'est que nous le voterons
quand même il vaut mieux tenir que
courir
merci Madame alors Monsieur Hainaut
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre alors nous voterons cette
amendement pour des motifs d'équilibre
des principes de d'équilibre de justice
et puis aussi de valeur
parce que évidemment il faut plus de
justice vis-à-vis des femmes il y a une
injustice ça a été dit au niveau de la
rémunération entre les femmes et les
hommes 10% à salaire à fonction égale ou
à diplôme égal et c'est insupportable
mais on peut pas tout attendre non plus
du du système de retraite je vais le
dire au collègue se soucier de cette
injustice à l'occasion d'une réforme de
du système de retraite c'est juste mais
on s'en est pas toujours soucier autant
et notamment à l'occasion de la réforme
Touraine sans ouvrir à nouveau la
polémique tout de même je veux le
signaler donc on peut pas tout attendre
de cette de cette réforme nous on aurait
même voulu peut-être aller plus loin
mais on prend effectivement
peut-être amendement et puis on a retiré
nos amendements pour que nous allions au
bout de cette discussion et nous y
tenons beaucoup et c'est pour nous
l'essentiel d'aller au bout de cette
discussion et puis pour des questions
d'équilibre aussi j'ai entendu madame
Vogel souvent je ne suis pas d'accord
avec elle mais je reconnais la
construction de de son argumentation
mais avec un système de retraite par
répartition il est tout à fait
indispensable légitime de s'occuper de
de démographie et de la dimension d'un
statut nataliste elle est intrinsèque au
système de répartition et enfin un
dernier mot sur la valeur pour nous la
famille ça n'est pas une j'ai entendu
tout ça tout à l'heure ça n'est ni une
idéologie ni une doctrine c'est une
valeur mes chers collègues la famille ni
une doctrine ni des login inédit mais
une valeur et et pour nous
mère de famille ça n'est pas un gros mot
père de famille ça n'est pas un gros mot
et la valeur c'est même une valeur
essentielle une cellule de base de la
société comme disait Victor Hugo la
famille c'est la plus solide des
forteresses je vous remercie
merci Monsieur mouillé
monsieur mouillé
monsieur Cabanel
merci Madame madame la Présidente
Monsieur ministre Richard collègue donc
pour une fois on prend pas la parole
souvent parce que dans mon groupe chacun
est libre de son vote et pour une fois
nous avons donc tous voté cet amendement
pour rendre la justice donc aux femmes
qui ont une carrière hachée mais je vais
profiter de la parole pour expliquer
donc ici quels sont notre quel est notre
frustration dans le groupe de voir ce
débat se dérouler comme il se déroule on
aimerait mieux qu'il y ait un véritable
débat ce qu'il me semble ne pas y avoir
alors certains reprochent à la majorité
sénatoriale d'avoir déclenché des
règlements
qui
mugellent un petit peu la parole des uns
et des autres je le regrette mais ils
n'ont été déclenchés qu'à partir de
l'article 7 et depuis le début il nous
semble que la gauche de cette hémicycle
veut ralentir le débat parce que moi
depuis que je suis dans cette maison
c'est la première fois que je vois des
amendements ident individuellement et
qui donc cherche à gagner du temps donc
nous dans notre ADN au sein du du RDSE
ce que nous voulons avant tout c'est
débattre et nous voulons aller jusqu'au
bout donc il faudrait clairement que
chacun se prononce sur la volonté
d'aller au bout parce que il est
important il est de notre responsabilité
de débattre et de faire en sorte que les
Français comprennent un petit peu mieux
quelle est la volonté des débats que
nous avons et en tout cas c'est pas
l'image me semble-t-il qu'on nous donne
aujourd'hui nous dans notre volonté
c'est d'aller jusqu'au bout merci
Monsieur chanterelle
chanterelle
merci madame la Présidente je voulais en
fait parler plus globalement de
l'article 8 en par parce que vous nous
en avez privé au tout début avec vos
artifices et votre volonté de nous
bâillonner au niveau des de nos prises
de parole au début
vous vous parlez de
des amandes
et je vous remercie de laisser le calme
qui règne là dans l'hémicycle je vous
rassure c'est en lieu
donc en tout cas c'est pas la présidence
qui parle c'est la présidence de la
droite on dirait mais bon
on voit en tout cas
vous pouvez demander une suspension de
séance je
reprends la parole monsieur chanterelle
monsieur chanterelle s'il vous plaît
je reprends la parole jamais vous
pourrez dire ça jamais tant mieux
pour tout le monde merci alors
maintenant je vous demande de faire
votre intervention et d'essayer de
garder le calme
alors
votre intimidation ne marchera pas merci
vous je sais que vous essayez je sais
que vous essayez de nous bâillonner de
nous intimider de plus plusieurs depuis
hier mais vous vous ne priverez pas les
français du débat
que ça soit à travers les coups de force
que vous faites depuis hier nous
continuerons nous continuerons à les
défendre même si ça vous plaît pas c'est
ça la démocratie il faut l'accepter donc
donc je par contre j'ai par contre j'ai
été coupé d'une minute mais bon
ce qu'il faut retenir justement de cet
article de du recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite à 64 ans
je vais demander une suspension de
séance madame la Présidente
c'est c'est que le recul de là ce sont
les plus fragiles justement ce dont
parle l'amendement de Monsieur Savary et
les plus fragilisés qui seront punis par
cette réforme et au premier chef celle
et ce qui bénéficient d'une retraite
anticipée comme le reste pas beaucoup de
temps je vais prendre le temps par
contre de les citer parce que ce sont
les personnes qui sont victimes
justement de votre de votre réforme ce
sont les titulaires d'une pension
d'invalidité les travailleurs déclarés
inapte au travail les allocataires de la
hache et de la location de cessation
anticipées d'activité les travailleurs
ayant eu une carrière longue les
travailleurs handicapés les travailleurs
qui ont une incapacité permanente à la
suite d'un accident du travail ou une
maladie professionnelle les
fonctionnaires handicapés les
fonctionnaires ayant eu
là c'est bon la parole est à Monsieur
karucci pour un rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente j'avais dit ce
matin que j'espérais je vous remercie
d'avoir suivi tout de suite
je me permets de dire à Monsieur
chanterelle et à l'ensemble de nos
collègues que si le climat restait
celui-là il faudrait appliquer la
totalité du règlement et dans la
totalité du règlement monsieur Chantrel
il y a un article 95 qui dit très
clairement que toute provocation toute
atteinte à la présidence de séance
entraîne la censure voir l'exclusion du
Sénat
pour un rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente je sais que vous
avez la faculté de savoir ce qu'il y a
dans les amendements avant même de les
lire c'est ce qui est arrivé hier avec
la présidente de roche déclarant une
erreur validité sans même avoir lu nos
amendements et là vous avez eu vous la
faculté madame la Présidente de savoir
ce que notre collègue chanterelle allait
dire avant même de l'écouter parce qu'il
a juste dit qu'on voulait nous
bâillonner il a le droit de le dire et
la suite la suite
laissez parler monsieur Durin vous allez
jusqu'au bout mais je vous inviterai à
relire le compte rendu ensuite on
regardera la vidéo ensemble donc
la suite de la défense de l'amendement
la suite de la défense de l'amendement a
prouvé qu'on était bien sur le fond donc
je crois qu'il faut si vous voulez
effectivement éviter d'en arriver à ces
extrémités que nous promet monsieur
karucci on n'est pas obligé d'en arriver
là on n'est pas obligé d'en arriver là
donc je sais que politiquement ça
devient compliqué sur ce texte parce
qu'on voit bien on a regardé les
rectifications de vote ça s'effrite et
puis on voit bien ce que dit la presse
locale c'est pas très populaire votre
position on comprend votre embarras on
comprend votre armoire donc laissez-nous
travailler vous connaissez notre
attachement à cette maison à l'ordre qui
règne à la qualité des débats qu'on sait
produire ensemble donc si vous
contribuez au calme et si tout se passe
bien vous pouvez compter sur nous
merci monsieur Durand mais il faut voir
les provocations de où elles viennent
quand même moi personnellement en tant
que Présidente je n'ai pas apprécié
voilà mes chers collègues je souhaite
sincèrement nos débats conservent la
sérénité qui fait la marque de fabrique
de notre assemblée et qui contribue à la
bonne image de notre travaux alors je
n'hésiterai pas afin de maintenir la
sérénité de nos débats à faire usage des
prérogatifs que le règlement confère à
la présidence de séance et se rappelle
ayant été fait nous reprenons le cours
normal de la discussion
et donc les explications de vote et
c'est Monsieur fier qui a la parole
merci madame la Présidente moi je
voterai l'amendement de notre apporteur
Savary et je ne le voterai pas parce que
j'ai l'article 7 honteux ou pour me
racheter ou pour me rattraper d'une
mauvaise action j'aurais commise au
contraire je le vote parce que il y a
une cohérence à demander certains
efforts et à corriger par ailleurs
certaines inégalités je moi je ne suis
pas économiste et je n'écoute pas les
économistes d'ailleurs parce que il y a
plutôt des raisons de s'en méfier moi je
me base sur ce que me disent les gens
que je rencontre qui travaillent aussi
dur que ceux que rencontrent la partie
gauche de cette hémicycle qui travaille
durement et qui ont aussi un peu de bon
sens quand l'espérance de vie augmente
de 10 ans depuis 40 ans quand il y a
plus de départ en retraite que de gens
qui rentrent sur le marché du travail
quand la démographie baisse écoutez il
n'y a pas besoin d'avoir fait
Polytechnique pour se dire que les
choses sont pas équilibrées et qu'avec
un peu de bon sens et bien il faut que
nous fassions tous un effort
supplémentaire et les gens qui
travaillent dur qui se lèvent tôt le
matin etc sont prêts aussi à le faire
quoi qu'on dise ils l'ont déjà fait par
exemple lorsqu'on a demandé de
travailler un jour de plus pour les
personnes âgées et la dépendance et je
crois que c'est aussi l'honneur de nos
concitoyens c'est la marque de la
solidarité nationale quand on veut une
retraite par répartition que malgré les
difficultés la dureté du travail que
l'on que l'on a et bien on puisse faire
cet effort supplémentaire pour
équilibrer un régime des retraites et
éviter à nos enfants de payer à la fois
nos retraites et des dettes que nous
leur laisserons
merci madame poncemo je prends un rappel
au règlement voilà on vient de voir un
nouvel échange tendu entre la droite et
la gauche sénatoriale autour de cet
article 8 on va rejoindre alexandre
Poussin Alex vous avez suivi ça au
premier loge vous êtes en tribune de
presse on peut le dire c'est débats se
tiennent au-dessus d'une Soufrière en
quelque sorte effectivement c'est de
plus en plus tendu cet après-midi dans
les débats entre les sénateurs et là on
a peut-être même franchi un cap puisque
les sénateurs discutaient de cet article
8 de la proposition de la droite
sénatoriale et bien de mettre en place
une surcote des pensions de retraite
pour les maires de famille un sénateur
socialiste Yann chanterelle a pris la
parole pour défendre un amendement alors
la règle c'est que le sénateur doit
parler de l'amendement du fond et pas
d'un sujet annexe et la présidente de
séance qui est une sénatrice LR Pascal
Gruny a estimé qu'il ne parlait pas du
fond de la discussion et le sénateur
socialicien de chanterelle lui a répondu
en disant qu'elle n'était pas la
présidente de séance c'est-à-dire de
toute l'institution sénatoriale mais
simplement la présidence des
républicains et ça c'est vraiment une
attaque qui a touché et bien à les
sénateurs les républicains il y a une
bronca dans l'hémicycle à la droite de
l'hémicycle car c'est vraiment et bien
une règle importante que la présidente
de séance en l'occurrence une
vice-présidente du Sénat soit neutre
représente toute l'institution et le
fait que la gauche estime qu'elle était
simplement la présidente des
républicains et bien Samy un peu le feu
aux poudres et à ce moment là un autre
vice-président du Sénat le sénateur les
républicains Roger carotic a pris la
parole en invoquant la possibilité d'un
article du règlement du Sénat qui évoque
et bien tout simplement l'exclusion d'un
sénateur qui attaquerait personnellement
la présidente d'une séance au Sénat donc
voilà la droite sénatoriale qui a menacé
d'exclusion le sénateur
socialiste Yann chanterel donc les
débats se sont vraiment un peu en
venimés on va le dire cet après-midi
avant de reprendre une discussion plus
calme qu'on entend à l'instant sur cet
article 8 voilà des menaces
d'utilisation d'un article de règlement
un articlement qui n'a jamais été
utilisé de l'histoire contemporaine
récente du Sénat retour dans les débats
dans l'émission
plein de surcote
ben oui et donc là c'est certes mieux
que ce que nous propose le prochain le
projet de loi mais c'est bien moins que
ce que les femmes ont aujourd'hui et en
plus et en plus elles ont pas le choix
j'allais le dire Raymonde voilà elle
n'empêche choix c'est-à-dire que
volontairement elles vont jusqu'à 64 ans
elles ont 10%, là on les oblige à aller
jusqu'à 64 ans il y a 62 elles ont la
totalité de leur trimestre et on va
gentiment leur donner 5 % alors chers
collègues rapporteur je sais que c'est
sincère mais moi ça me plaît pas je sais
que beaucoup y compris voilà dans les
dans les rangs qui sont les miens trouve
que c'est plutôt pas mal moi à titre à
titre personnel à titre personnel
j'avoue que ça me c'est un amendement
qui ne qui ne me dérange pas bien
évidemment parce que parce que il est
construit et tout ce qu'on veut mais
c'est un je ne le partage pas parce que
finalement c'est moins
que ce que elles ont aujourd'hui
merci Madame Vogel
merci madame la Présidente donc en effet
je crois que c'est important de le dire
et de le dire clairement l'amendement
sur lequel nous sommes amenés à voter va
consister à faire perdre des droits aux
femmes qui ont des enfants mais un peu
moins que ce qui avait prévu le
gouvernement aujourd'hui les femmes qui
atteignent le taux plein à 62 ans avec
leur trimestre de majoration peuvent
choisir de s'arrêter de prendre leur
retraite à 62 ans ou bien de continuer à
travailler et dans ce cas là si elles
vont jusqu'à 64 ans elle bénéficie d'une
charcute de 10%
donc ce qui nous est proposé ici né en
aucun cas un progrès par rapport à
l'existant c'est un moindre recul pour
les seules personnes qui ont fait le
choix d'avoir des enfants ça n'aura
aucun effet sur les inégalités
structurelles entre les femmes et les
hommes dans la société que nous avons
proposé à de nombreuses reprises de
corrigés par tout un tas de mesure que
vous avez systématiquement refusé je
voudrais juste finir en disant que pour
moi la famille n'est pas une valeur la
famille c'est une institution et comme
tous les institutions mais c'est pas un
gros mot institution excusez moi je sais
pas ce que c'est le problème que vous
avez avec le mot institution c'est une
institution comme toutes les
institutions ce sont des constructions
sociales et comme toutes les
constructions sociales elles ont
vocation à évoluer et nous avons le
projet de faire évoluer la famille pour
qu'elle soit moins concentrée sur l'idée
que la fille que la famille est une
affaire de femmes que les femmes sont là
pour faire des enfants et pour s'en
occuper
si Monsieur Chaumier
[Applaudissements]
merci
la Présidente je vais de expliquer
qu'elle va être mon vote puisque c'est
l'objet de cette intervention de cet
article auparavant je voulais dire que
les débats sont cette hémicycle même
s'ils sont entendus ne sont pas inutiles
et j'en veux pour preuve que depuis que
le vote a eu lieu sur le report à 64 ans
il y a une petite dizaine de collègues
qui ont abandonné le vote pour et l'ont
transformé en contre-abstention ce qui
veut dire que les arguments les
explications finissent par voilà un flux
sur notre position à chacun je voudrais
dire à mon collègue Bernard fialer
d'ailleurs que ce qui compte ça n'est
pas l'espérance de vie c'est l'espérance
de vie en bonne santé et quel stagne et
on ne sait pas ce qu'elle sera à
l'avenir d'ailleurs l'espérance de vie
globale va probablement régresser dans
les années à venir en tout cas comme aux
États-Unis l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé on n'en sait pas trop et je
conçois que cette définition est
d'ailleurs assez complexe mais toujours
est-il que quand on se fixe à cet
indicateur il n'y a pas vraiment de
motif d'arguments pour reporter l'âge
légal de la part de départ à retraite et
puis sur cette amendement du rapporteur
moi malgré les conditions dans lequel il
a été présentée et ce qui est une
manœuvre même si elle est réglementaire
qui a été menée pour aboutir à son
examen en priorité
évidemment c'est la question du verre à
moitié vide à moitié plein ou faut-il
atténuer accepter de voter l'atténuation
d'une d'un cadre général qui est très
négatif et c'était une atténuation qui
est partielle donc évidemment notre
groupe il réfléchit on est traversé on
est traversé sur cette question on n'a
pas une on n'est pas arrivé nous dans
cette hémicycle en ces temps mis
d'accord avec le gouvernement surtout et
en ayant une position de principe
surtout et donc je dis pas que tout le
monde on a vu que les votes changent je
l'ai dit donc je reconnais l'évolution
de chacun et donc peut-être que nos
votes seront différents sur cette
question moi je vais plutôt accepter la
proposition du rapporteur avec toutes
les réserves que j'ai expliqué merci
Monsieur longuet
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le
groupe républicain soutient avec
conviction l'amendement 21-27 rectifiée
le soutien avec conviction parce que
c'est amendement à l'immense mérite
d'ouvrir enfin le débat sur une réalité
française c'est que le régime par
répartition ne peut durer que si nous
avons un équilibre des naissances au
regard de la durée de la vie en retraite
or vous évoquez avec nostalgie le CNR
qui en effet au printemps 1944 avant que
la France même soit libérée a fondé une
politique sociale
dont auquel auquel appartient évidemment
ce régime par répartition nous avions à
l'époque et les circonstances étaient
quand même tragiques pour notre pays une
natalité de 21 pour 1000
aujourd'hui nous sommes à 11 pour 1000
c'est-à-dire à peu près moitié moins
cette décrue a été particulièrement
forte au début du 21e siècle nous étions
encore à 14 pour 1000 en 2000 nous
sommes aujourd'hui à 11 pour 1000 il y a
une véritable interrogation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente pour ma part
je voterai cet amendement du rapporteur
Savary mais je le dis très honnêtement
je le vaut très par défaut
par défaut parce que
l'article 7 qui porte à 64 ans la mesure
d'âge plus l'amendement ça varie à cet
article 8 qui crée une surcote à 5%, ça
crée par rapport à la situation actuelle
c'est de articles additionnés ça crée un
recul un recul qui est plus limité que
le recul créé par le simple vote de
l'article 7 que vous avez voté hier
nuitamment mais un recul quand on
aggrave avec deux ans de plus puis qu'on
atténue avec une surcote cela reste une
aggravation c'est une aggravation
atténuée mais c'est une aggravation ma
deuxième remarque c'est que je le redis
j'ai entendu hier ou avant-hier une
proposition sur les groupes du centre
pour ne pas imposer le recul de la
mesure d'âge et je le dis c'est pareil
la surcote devrait rester un choix
personnel vous chers qui êtes les
apôtres de la liberté très souvent
pourquoi ne pas laisser aux gens le
choix de la liberté parce qu'il y a des
personnes qui peuvent être cassées et
qui peuvent aspirer absolument à prendre
le retraites même avec une décote vous
le savez très bien d'ailleurs c'est déjà
le cas aujourd'hui donc laissons le
choix ne retardons pas la possibilité
pour chacune en l'occurrence de prendre
la retraite au moment où elle le décide
et laissons ce choix et puis enfin il me
reste que 14 secondes je veux dire que
je ne comprends pas ce débat sur le fait
que le travail ou la famille sont des
valeurs et j'aimerais qu'on prenne le
temps d'un débat évidemment un loi un
texte de loi de finance rectificative ne
se prête pas contraint dans le temps de
se prête sans doute pas à ce débat mais
c'est un débat très important et très
intéressant et la famille a beaucoup
changé vous le savez parfaitement donc
je ne sais pas ce que représente cette
valeur en tous les cas ce que je fais
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de familles
pour différentes merci merci Madame
meunier
merci madame la Présidente je pense
qu'on assiste là un beau moment de débat
parlementaire moi j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire avec la prise de parole sur
l'amendement et l'article 8 et donc
l'amendement présenté par notre
rapporteur Savary
par cet amendement les choses ne sont
pas réglées dans les inégalités entre
les femmes et les hommes les inégalités
de salaire les inégalités de pension les
accès à des métiers qui sont encore trop
réservés à des femmes dans des
catégories de domaine du médico-social
du soin des services à la personne bref
cet amendement ne règle pas c'est
amendement règles la question des femmes
qui ont trois enfants et qui ont vont
bénéficier d'une surcote moi j'ai pensé
au départ que c'était un peu meilleur
que s'il y avait rien la citation
actuelle mais en vous entendant mes
chers collègues plutôt ici je sais pas
s'il faut voter cet amendement en tout
cas le doute s'est installé en moi et je
pense que au final je m'abstiendrai
désolé monsieur ça va
si Monsieur mouillé
merci Madame le présidente j'aurai une
intervention en trois points tout
d'abord première intervention pour
soutenir l'amendement de rapporteur et
la remercier d'avoir trouvé cette cette
plus-value notamment qui remet en valeur
notamment la natalité et donc les places
des femmes dans notre société on regarde
un effort collectif collectivement nous
nous mobilisons pour travailler plus
longtemps pour l'équilibre de nos
retraites et je crois que c'est un signe
important de pouvoir bien apporter cette
cette plus-value donc c'est pour moi la
première intervention deuxième
intervention on a beaucoup entendu des
des dans le débat des questionnements
sur l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes en matière de rémunération en
matière d'emploi c'est un vrai sujet
c'est un sujet que de pour lequel de
cela doit s'emparer mais ce n'est pas du
tout l'objet du texte ce n'est pas du
tout l'objet du texte et donc
aujourd'hui nous devons nous concentrer
sur les enjeux concernant l'équilibre de
nos retraites et puis troisième point
concernant les personnes handicapées
j'ai entendu beaucoup d'interventions en
disant aujourd'hui la situation va être
beaucoup plus difficile
ils sont dans l'effort collectifs mais
si vous regardez bien l'ensemble du
texte vous prenez le temps de lire le
texte aujourd'hui pour eux rien ne va
changer puisque de nouveau l'âge de 55
ans sera un âge barrière pour pouvoir
pas arrêter en retraite anticipée
simplement dans les évolutions proposées
par le gouvernement ont simplifie des
procédures et donc on améliore leurs
conditions voilà je voulais le dire
parce que j'entends beaucoup de choses
autour de tout ça et si vous vous
souciez aujourd'hui de l'enjeu du
médico-social au cours de ces débats sur
les retraites moi j'ai un peu des
services à vous demander collectivement
demander à ceux qui sont en train de
couper l'électricité en France des
établissements médico-sociaux d'arrêter
on aura un enjeu fondamental pour nous
merci Monsieur Retailleau sur le
président Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
c'est un moment du débat qui est
intéressant puisque je remercie le
rapporteur d'avoir porté cet amendement
dont nous avions fait auprès du
gouvernement je vous le rappelle chers
collègues une vraie ligne rouge il est
intéressant ce débat pour deux raisons
il est intéressant d'abord parce que on
assiste à un rarement
d'une presque convergence entre nous ça
a été Rare il faut le souligner il est
aussi intéressant sur le plan politique
parce que vous voyez durant ces derniers
jours j'avais été accusé puisqu'à
l'origine aussi de cette amendement
j'avais été accusé de vouloir absolument
une politique nataliste et que la
politique catalyse était l'abomination
des abominations et je vois qu'il y a
une grande partie de la gauche qui est
restée fidèle à son héritage l'héritage
du franc populaire qui a inventé la
location familiale universelle enrichie
ensuite avec le gaullisme le CNR ils ont
fondé les socles d'une politique
familiale nataliste pour ceux qui aiment
l'histoire bien sûr il y a une petite
partie de la gauche
rare ici dans notre hémicycle qui
considère que évidemment la famille ça
n'est pas une valeur et que il faut
déconstruire tout cela qu'il faut
tourner le dos à ces cadres collectifs à
un destin commun au profit d'une
émancipation individuelle radicale
je suis heureux que au Sénat il yesset
de gauche social qui persiste et je me
suis toujours
j'ai regretté dans ma prof à vie
politique des dérives idéologiques pour
pouvoir le dire ici au sujet de la
gauche c'est un homme fondamental parce
que l'impensé de la réforme du
gouvernement c'est la démographie un
régime par répartition c'est un régime
justement de transition démographique et
intergénérationnel les femmes sont déjà
les grandes perdantes puisque vous
l'avez tous souligné les maires de
famille encore plus puisqu'on écrase les
trimestres de majoration avec les deux
années de recul c'est quelque chose de
fondamental on ne peut pas penser
l'avenir de notre régime sans une
politique familiale qui soit une
politique familiale vraiment vigoureuse
et volontaire merci Monsieur le cas
[Applaudissements]
or si Madame la
je voulais remercier Monsieur
Retailleau pour contribution à
l'histoire du Front populaire
je voulais lui dire que cette
contribution est quelque peu orientés et
que c'est tout à fait contraire à la
réalité que de considérer que les hommes
et les femmes les ministres hommes et
femmes femmes et hommes qui étaient dans
le gouvernement du Front populaire était
contre ou aurait été contre une
politique de la famille ils ont au
contraire
fait beaucoup
fait beaucoup ils ont fait beaucoup à
cet égard ainsi et je vais dire aussi
que
nous nous instruisons chers collègues
dans le droit fil de cette politique du
Front populaire et quand vous essayez
quand vous essayez de nous présenter
comme étant en contradiction avec le
Front populaire franchement c'est une
imposture que nous ne pouvons accepter
merci chers collègues passer la parole à
Monsieur le Président Laurent
c'est ce que vient de dire le président
Retailleau qui m'incite à faire à mon
tour une explication de vote parce qu'il
faut être d'accord sur le sens de ce que
nous allons voter les uns et les autres
vous parlez de ligne rouge sur le
taillot pour ce qui est de la réforme
des retraites c'est une ligne Maginot
parce que la régression sociale
va être massive avec les 64 ans et elle
va être massive pour tout le monde et
pour les maires de famille comme pour
les autres donc sa né en aucun cas une
ligne rouge qui empêche cette régression
sociale massive donc nous ne sommes pas
en train de créer une conquête sociale
puisque vous avez fait référence aux
Front populaire qui a été une période de
grande conquête sociale nous sommes
entrons dans le meilleur des cas
d'essayer de limiter un tout petit peu
les dégâts que va provoquer la réforme
que vous voulez absolument voter et la
deuxième chose que je veux dire c'est
qu'en matière de politique familiale
le plus grave coût qui était porté à la
politique familiale française c'est le
jour où on a décidé que les entreprises
seraient totalement dégagées du
financement des allocations familiales
parce que vous avez décidé ce jour-là de
fiscaliser entièrement la politique
familiale et comme vous êtes les
premiers à expliquer tous les jours
qu'il faut baisser les dépenses
publiques c'est vous qui tarissez la
possibilité d'avoir une politique
familiale ambitieuse parce que vous avez
dégagé les entreprises
et la création de valeur ajoutée des
responsabilités en la matière et que
vous êtes les premiers à faire pression
sur le niveau des dépenses publiques et
des dépenses sociales donc ne nous
donnez pas des leçons en matière de
politique familiale merci
alors je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur le Rapporteur Savary et je vous
invite à rejoindre vos bancs pour le
scrutin public qui aura lieu ensuite
monsieur Kerrouche attendez monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur qui est rouge veut
prendre la parole
on réagit tout ça
on réagit tout ça aux prises de parole
qui ont été dites et justement pour
corriger
tu veux plus parler
je suis sûr que ça vous aurait manqué
donc je rallume
pourtant pourtant il va falloir
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
je suis pas étonné quand même que notre
collègue Bruno Retailleau ne veulent pas
ne veulent pas franchir la ligne rouge
j'en ai jamais douté
sur le sur le sur le fond on peut dire
que cet amendement fait que les choses
soient moins pires que pire mais
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
elle est avérée elle était verrée aussi
au moment de au moment de la retraite il
y a un écart de 28% sur les droits à la
retraite entre les hommes et les femmes
et quand on prend en compte uniquement
les droits directs et pas les droits
dérivés cet écart monte à 41%. donc il y
a une vraie difficulté et j'en viens à
toujours cette ce problème que notre
collègue fièrent à évoqué tout à l'heure
vous avez dit mais cette réforme c'est
le bon sens parce que on vit plus
longtemps et donc d'une certaine façon
il n'y a pas besoin de sortir de
Polytechnique pour comprendre qu'il faut
faire plus rien n'est plus faux rien
n'est plus faux parce que encore une
fois je vous le répète vous raisonnez
sur des moyennes et en statistique ça
n'a pas de sens la moyenne est une
valeur générale ce qui compte c'est
l'écart à la moyenne et l'écart à la
moyenne il est complètement différent en
fonction du sexe et en fonction de la
catégorie sociale et en fonction du
revenu donc faire comme si la moyenne
concernait tout le monde c'est
complètement faux certains sont
directement touchés et impactés et faire
croire comme le gouvernement que cette
réforme est une réforme de bon sens
c'est justement un non-sens statistique
une erreur politique et une erreur
sociale
merci alors le scrutin public c'est sur
l'amendement avant je ferai sur
l'amendement
bah oui bien sûr
en fait j'ai donné la parole pour les
explications de vote surtout quoi mais
donc voilà il y a pas de souci merci de
votre générosité je voulais dire au
président Retailleau que je vais vous
prendre pendant deux minutes madame la
Présidente moi je suis disponible pour
un débat sur les questions
démographiques sur la question de la
natalité et sur les politiques
familiales mais je pense que d'abord il
faut passer par une analyse sérieuse de
ce qui aujourd'hui nous amène au chiffre
que vous avez donné d'un peu plus 700
000 naissances par an bon
on observe qu'est-ce qui à mon sens
aujourd'hui est la principale cause des
hésitations des jeunes couples à mettre
des enfants au monde premièrement les
inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes aujourd'hui des jeunes femmes
conçoivent leur vie les jeunes femmes se
posent laissez-moi finir président
Retailleau je vous ai dit laissez-moi
finir quand vous demandez à une jeune
femme quelle est la carrière qu'elle
veut faire des femmes très diplômées
elles vous répondent celles qui me
permettra d'avoir une vie compatible
avec ma vie familiale vous posez la
question aux garçons de la même
promotion ils répondent pas ça donc les
jeunes gens projettent leur avenir en
fonction des charges de famille et pour
les jeunes femmes l'âge du premier
enfant qui devrait sujet c'est l'âge de
naissance du premier enfant il ne peut
arriver que quand tout est sécurisé la
carrière le logement
le couple tout ça et donc et donc nous
avons la premier sujet deuxième le sujet
qui on peut comprendre que des jeunes
gens entre 25 et 35 ans s'interroge pour
savoir à quoi ressemblera le monde
demain dans lequel vont vivre leurs
enfants on peut pas on peut pas
la meilleure des politiques familiales
c'est aujourd'hui de rassurer les jeunes
sur le fait que nous prendrons toutes
les mesures nécessaires pour garantir à
leurs enfants de l'eau de l'air et un
climat bien sûr que si des fois anxiété
est une donnée majeure comme l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes mais quand vous voulez on fait un
grand débat au Sénat moi je demande que
ça merci à la présente donc je vais
donner la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur
très bien merci effectivement et si on
veut donner envie aux jeunes il faut
aussi quelque part que dans notre
discours nous n'ayons pas toujours un
discours minérabilisme ou apocalyptique
quand on parle du travail me semble-t-il
[Applaudissements]
moi je voudrais amener quelques
précisions parce que ce débat était
intéressant mais il y a eu également
quelques imprécisions
pour me permettrait de les aborder je
risque de déporter quelques mais juste
une minute ou deux je vais être le plus
synthétique possible mais il me semble
que c'est tout à fait important de
rétablir effectivement il y a des
majorations trimestres qui sont perdus
comme on peut dire effacer en tout cas
elle rentre pas en compte ni dans la
durée ni effectivement bien sûr dans le
compte dans le montant de la pension
mais en tout cas dans la durée du fait
de quoi on nous sommes à 20% de
majoration qui soit actuellement perdu
quand on allonge l'âge on sera à 30%.
mais sauf que elles sont on a un taux de
20% parce qu'il y a déjà le commencement
de l'application de la loi Touraine et
vous perdez des majorations à la fois
quand vous n'avez pas vos 43 triestres
c'est sur la longueur et également par
le décalage de l'âge c'est pour ça que
c'est très forme fait que effectivement
il y aura un décalage de majoration et
ça nous a pas échappé c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons convenu que une
majoration méritait qu'elle soit pris en
compte et
cette mesure s'adresse
parfois aux hommes mais
principalement majoritairement aux
femmes
choix ou pas le choix on n'a pas le
choix vous dites on a plus le choix du
fait de du décalage de l'âge mais on n'a
pas plus le choix du fait de
l'allongement de la durée voilà parce
que si vous allez à l'âge et la palette
à durée vous n'avez pas le taux plein et
si vous allez durer mais vous n'avez pas
là mais il faut continuer à travailler
donc les deux facteurs ces deux piliers
jouent c'est la subtilité du dispositif
qui à travers nos raisonnements parfois
nous échapper et je le comprends tout à
fait bien parce que j'avoue que j'ai mis
aussi longtemps pour parfois le
comprendre on dit que effectivement par
rapport à la surcotte aujourd'hui une
femme de 62 ans elle part 62 ans et
trimestre
sauf que pour arriver à avoir ces 43
trimestres déjà 62 ans faut avoir
commencé à 19 ans les 43 années
excusez-moi merci les 43 années faut
commencer à 19 ans quand même donc on
touche pas toutes les femmes voyez il y
a beaucoup de femmes qui sont
effectivement avec une durée déjà plus
importante un autre dispos si vous dites
avec la surcote demain il y a pas la
surcotte elle va avoir moins de sous ben
non non parce qu'elles vont travailler
effectivement là le fait borne fait que
et ça a été bien compris et c'est pour
ça qu'il y a un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont mécontent l'effet
born force à travailler plus longtemps
moi je le reconnais bien volontiers
c'est le principe de la réforme de force
mais c'est la philosophie même de la
réforme sauf que effectivement j'aurais
peut-être une surcote mais comme elle
travaille plus longtemps comme elle
travaille plus longtemps elles auront un
salaire qui fait qui il y aura
effectivement une rémunération plus
importante et si c'est quelqu'un dans la
fonction publique comment calcule la
retraite sur les six derniers mois
qu'elle aura son indice indiciaire qui
va augmenter donc elle aura une
meilleure retraite donc elle rattrapera
éventuellement la surcote c'est la
raison pour laquelle cette mesure de 5%
et tout à fait significative dites-le
autour de vous si vous votez cela parce
que vous pourrez dire on a quand même
essayé d'améliorer votre pension même si
ça vient nous ne vous gênez pas pour le
dire
un autre point que je voulais simplement
signaler c'est que vous avez largement
dénoncé et injuste titre que le système
était inégalitaire par rapport notamment
au maire de famille mais dans d'autres
dispositifs et on a assisté je ne sais
plus quelle
diatride là-dessus sur les différences
de traitement pour l'usure
professionnelle l'incapacité permanente
qui faisait que etc un certain nombre de
dispositifs inégalitaires et nous
l'avons constaté le principe de cette
réforme c'est que ce soit le moins
inégalitaire possible dans ces
dispositifs en conséquence c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous invite dans
le cas de cette réflexion
à suivre ce qui sera proposé dans
l'article dans le l'amendement de
Monsieur retaillod en ce qui concerne
les régimes spéciaux parce que nous
avons le même raisonnement faut trouver
une durée de retraite qui soit fonction
si elle est plus longue que les autres
de l'usure professionnelle et il s'agit
que tout le monde soit traité à la même
enseigne c'est pour ça qu'il est permis
sans animosité de faire en sorte que
l'on puisse avoir cette égalité sans
attendre 70 ans mais en essayant d'avoir
un délai un petit peu plus contraint
voilà la réflexion qui a animé la
Commission en tout cas merci de soutenir
cet abonnement c'est tout à fait décisif
merci à Bruno Retailleau de l'avoir
proposé merci alors je vais mettre voir
non j'ai
après on passe au vote
je vais très court je vais être très
court mais toujours pour reprendre un
peu notre rapporteur quelquefois
comment dire s'envole un petit peu en
disant si vous le votez n'oubliez pas de
rappeler qu'ils viennent de nous
qu'ils viennent de nous je parle à sa
place c'est ce qu'il vient de dire et il
y a juste un petit problème que je
rappelle encore une fois c'est que
toutes les améliorations éventuelles
toutes les petites améliorations qui
peuvent subvenir ne peuvent venir que de
vous puisque il s'agit d'un accord
préalable avec le gouvernement vous
autorisant à déposer l'amendement parce
que si le gouvernement avait dit non
vous étiez article 40 et il y aurait pas
dans l'amélioration donc bien sûr que
nous ne le dirons pas
merci monsieur le Président alors je
mets aux voix donc les sous amendements
donc le premier c'est le 4876 le dernier
excusez-moi sont
identiques
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ne sont pas adoptées et
je vais passer au vote donc de
l'amendement 2127 de la commission avec
un avis favorable du Gouvernement donc
qui se fait sur la forme du scrutin
public il va être procédé donc au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
voilà on est en train de vivre ce
scrutin public à l'antenne de Public
Sénat inscritin sur un amendement venu
de la droite et du centre un scrutin
autour d'un amendement très important la
surcote pour les femmes qui ont eu au
moins un enfant et qui ont toutes leurs
annuités et qui et bien lorsqu'ils
lorsqu'elle travaille entre 63 et 64 ans
vont bénéficier d'une surcote de 1,25%
par trimestre supplémentaire pour un
donc et bien le fait d'avoir eu un
enfant une forme de compensation
peut-être un des effets négatifs de la
réforme des retraites en tout cas c'est
ce que disent la droite et le centre
lorsqu'ils ont proposé et cette
modification on va en reparler avec
notre journaliste Alexandre poussat
juste après le résultat de ce scrutin
Alexandre qui va pouvoir nous dire
exactement ce qui se joue avec ce débat
autour de cet amendement de la
commission un moment défendu par René
Paul Savary qui donc tient la position
de la droite et du centre au Sénat sur
réforme on va suivre la suite et la fin
de ce scrutin public souhaitant
électronique et non pas un scrutin à
main levée un scrutin électronique qui
va permettre de connaître la position de
tous les sénateurs sur cet amendement
sont-ils pour sont-ils contre on va voir
le descriptif précis dans l'hémicycle du
vote sur cette amendement un amendement
qui aura pris de longues heures d'examen
puisque on a vu un débat depuis
plusieurs heures autour de la réforme
pour les femmes autour également du fait
qu'il y avait des écarts de salaire
entre les hommes et les femmes Laurence
Rossignol qui a appelé ce chiffre de 35%
d'écart en moyenne et donc on a entendu
la gauche qui a expliqué que d'allonger
l'âge de départ pénalise
particulièrement les femmes qui ont le
plus des carrières hachées ou des petits
salaires au cours de leur vie
professionnelle mais donc cet amendement
suffira-t-il à rattraper ses effets
sur les carrières des femmes c'est en
tout cas ce que dit la droite alors que
plus personne ne demande à voter et
qu'on va pouvoir avoir le résultat du
scrutin on écoute le résultat on en
reparle juste après avec Alexandre
leurs résultats du scrutin nombre de
votants 344 exprimés 280 pour 280 contre
0 le Sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
en conséquence tous les amendements de
suppression tombent
et j'ai aussi deux amendements qui
tombent le 4329 de même la présidente
assassin
et le 2863 de Madame Lubin
et donc nous avons 11 amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
c'est même lui voilà le Sénat qui vient
d'adopter cet amendement Savary sur la
surcote pour les femmes ayant eu au
moins un enfant 280 voix pour et
l'abstention donc d'une partie de la
gauche on va rejoindre alexandre Poussin
Alexandre vous êtes en tribune de presse
dites-nous tout sur les débats des
débats intéressants sur les carrières
des femmes on peut le dire et qu'est-ce
que vous avez vous retenus de ces
échanges très bien content on peut dire
que le débat s'est élevé ces dernières
minutes dans l'hémicycle du Sénat autour
de cet amendement sur la proposition de
la droite sanitaire de mettre en place
une surcote des pensions de retraite des
maires de famille sur les trimestres
cotisés à partir de 63 ans on va d'abord
écouter l'auteur de l'amendement le
rapporteur de la républicain René Paul
Sabri qui explique pourquoi c'est la
meilleure solution pour nuancer un petit
peu les pénalités des femmes dans cette
réforme des retraites c'est même un
membre du gouvernement qui avait admis
que les femmes étaient un petit peu plus
pénalisées dans cette réforme des
retraites par rapport aux hommes écouter
René Paul Savary qui explique que c'est
la meilleure solution pour compenser un
petit peu ses pénalités on peut pas
avoir comme argument de donner une durée
de retrait plus élevée aux femmes par
rapport aux hommes parce que il n'y a
pas de différence
dans l'espérance de vie c'est la même et
en conséquence nous rentrons dans une un
droit qui sur le plan européen est un
droit discriminatif des hommes par
rapport aux femmes donc nous n'avons pas
retenu ce type de dispositif voilà ce
qui nous a animé et à faire cette
proposition d'une surcote anticipée
voilà et cette surcote qui permet de
résoudre l'un des problèmes de cette
réforme de retraite c'est que les
trimestres gagnaient notamment par les
maires de famille grâce à leur
parentalité et bien certains trimestres
gagnés étaient annulés par ce relèvement
de l'âge de départ à 64 ans alors du
côté de la gauche et bien justement les
stateurs de gauche étaient divisés sur
cette surcote proposée par la droite
sénatoriale certains estimaient que et
bien c'était plutôt une bonne
proposition d'autres ne comprenaient pas
pourquoi et bien c'était uniquement les
maires de famille qui étaient concernées
par cet amendement et pourquoi il n'y
avait pas justement un amendement pour
toucher les inégalités dont les femmes
étaient victimes par rapport aux hommes
et justement c'est cette question des
inégalités salariales entre les femmes
et les hommes qui a été rappelé dans le
débat par Laurence Rossignol la
sénatrice socialiste les femmes qui
n'ont pas d'enfants sont dans la même
situation l'écart résiduel de
rémunération entre les femmes et les
hommes et de 9% indépendamment des
carrières celui qui reste à post égal
travailler égal diplôme égal donc en
excluant toutes les femmes qui ne sont
pas mère de famille de cet amendement
vous ne répondez pas à l'écart de
rémunération spécifique entre les femmes
et les hommes qui impactent également la
carrière des femmes qui ne sont pas mère
de famille
et puis c'était ce débat était aussi
très intéressant car il est venu sur la
question de la natalité puisque la
droite sénatoriale avec cet amendement
veut défendre une politique nataliste
pour la France pour faire face aux
déclin des naissances dans notre pays et
donc le président du groupe les
républicains Bruno Retailleau a défendu
cet amendement avec vraiment une vision
nataliste pour résoudre le problème
démographique qui est un problème majeur
selon lui pour notre régime des
retraites et en face la gauche à défendu
une vision sur Noël qui est un petit peu
réactionnaire et qui réduit la femme
justement à sa fonction reproductrice à
la charge démographique qui pèse sur
elle donc voilà on a eu un débat très
intéressant sur la natalité Quentin
merci merci Alexandre Poussard pour
toutes ces explications depuis la
tribune de presse et donc je vous le
rappelle le Sénat qui adopte cette
surcote pour les femmes qui ont eu au
moins un enfant lorsqu'elles atteignent
l'âge de 63 ans elle cotise en plus
jusqu'à 64 ans pour cette surcote 280
voix pour zéro contre retour dans les
débats en direct comme
que le
fait inscrire dans la loi c'est notre
rôle par ailleurs pour conclure
présenter ces mesures de statu quo de
faible avancée comme de véritables
progrès sociaux est une hypocrisie alors
que l'économie générale c'est-à-dire la
tendance de fond conduit à une
aggravation
y compris pour les personnes invalides
ou en situation de bon là je n'a pas été
modifié je vous remercie
le 417 monsieur ferick
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre collègues nous avons souvent
alerté le gouvernement et quand je dis
nous je parle de notre chambre haute sur
les dérives de ce gouvernement dans son
rapport au corps législatif procédure
accélérée devenue la norme non
ratification des ordonnances renvoie
constant au décret sous couvert
d'efficacité toutes ces décisions
éloignent la représentation nationale de
dispositions importantes les retire de
la discussion nous avons bien vu que
dans la construction de ce texte sur
l'avenir des retraites le gouvernement
ne s'était guère embarrassé d'écouter
les syndicats les partis politiques ou
même le Conseil d'État nous empêchant
même de pouvoir nous nous les écouter en
maintenant secrètent la note qui aurait
pu et dû éclairer nos échanges cet
article 8 est représentatif passez-moi
l'expression du bricolage du
gouvernement des annonces de progrès
social mais sans réel mesure de progrès
social notre amendement souhaite donc
rendre concrète les annonces non dites
par le gouvernement le présent article
prévoit plus particulièrement que
l'inval l'inaptitude où vous ouvre droit
un départ anticipé à un âge fixé par
décret en plus du bénéfice d'une
retraite au temps plein à cet âge il est
ainsi prévu que cet âge soit maintenu à
62 ans par décret notre groupe ne
souhaite pas laisser de place à des
renvois en décret les discussions de ces
derniers jours ont montré comment comme
l'absence de décret a pu impacter le
calcul des retraites des enseignants par
exemple il nous paraît donc nécessaire
de fixer dès maintenant ces tâches
anticipées de manière aussi fixe que
celui fixé dans l'article 7 de la loi je
vous remercie de votre attention merci
le 28 61 madame Lubin
c'est un amendement qui vise à garantir
que l'âge de départ anticipé à la
retraite pour les allocataires de
l'allocation de cessation anticipées
d'activités les travailleurs ayant eu
une carrière longue les travailleurs
handicapés les travailleurs t'ont une
incapacité permanente à la suite d'un
accident du travail ou une maladie
professionnelle sera toujours de 62 ans
et non prendre cette disposition par
décret comme cela est proposé
actuellement
merci le
4580 monsieur Ferny
alors que le gouvernement limite
fortement le débat Parlement pardon
excusez-moi
madame la ministre madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je m'excuse chers
collègues
alors que le gouvernement limite
fortement le débat parlementaire est
réduit à peu de choses la concertation
avec les organisations syndicales nous
demandons par cet amendement de faire
des négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux organisation syndicales et
patronales représentatives au niveau
national et interprofessionnel un point
de passage obligé préalable au décret
merci le 2126 de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
un moment de coordination
des nations madame la Présidente merci
avis du gouvernement
annoncé vraiment
manque un peu de sommeil
alors troisièmement identique le 2846
madame Lubin même Poumirol
oui merci madame la Présidente
encore une fois viens marquer notre
refus de décalage de l'âge de la
retraite de deux ans et donc c'est à
m'en demande du groupe socialiste vise à
ne pas décaler de deux ans pour les
salariés qui sont affectés par des
risques professionnels puisqu'on sait
que dans leur cas la situation est
encore plus pénible et encore plus grave
donc nous demande donc à ce qui n'est
pas de recul
qu'est-ce que je dois
donnez moi une seconde
3374 madame ponce
oui merci madame la Présidente alors je
voudrais revenir sur le C2P vous nous
dites que c'est il est au titre de du
C2P
vous maintenez deux ans avant mais les
départs anticipés au titre du C2P vous
êtes bien d'accord désormais ne pourront
intervenir qu'à 62 ans nous proposons
par cet amendement de maintenir la
possibilité d'un départ anticipé à 60
ans pour
pour le C2P pour les
départs anticipés pour pénibilité c'est
dispositions surviennent alors que le
travail s'intensifie depuis 30 ans je
reviendrai pas sur les chiffres de la
DARES selon les chercheurs Thomas Barney
et Eric de Faivre la retraite présente
des effets bénéfiques pour la santé et
le bien-être de façon générale mais
vraiment plus pour les catégories
populaires largement exposées à
l'accroissement de la pénibilité au
travail selon eux le rôle protecteur de
la prise de retraite reste très prononcé
parmi les personnes dont le travail a
été éprouvant pour les personnes
confrontées à des contraintes physiques
la retraite améliore principalement la
santé générale mais ne répare pas
toujours les corps pour autant tandis
que pour les personnes ayant subi des
contraintes psychosociales et bien
effectivement ça s'accompagne d'une
diminution
sensible de l'anxiété de la dépression
pour la population masculine la plus
exposée à des contraintes physiques ils
observent que la retraite permet une
diminution des maladies chroniques de
13%, une baisse de l'anxiété de la
dépression de 8% et une baisse qui est
importante pour l'espérance de vie sans
un sans incapacité une baisse de 16% de
la limitation d'activité aussi le
meilleur remède à la pénibilité du C2P
c'est donc la retraite arrêtez d'user
les cordes des travailleurs de ce pays
monsieur le ministre et monsieur le
ministre
des manifestants voulant appeler ils ne
veulent plus perdre leur vie à la gagner
si le 433 c'est qu'il défend
madame réaum
merci madame la Présidente c'est un
moment vise à ne pas décaler de deux ans
là je n'ai pas anticipé pour les
salariés affectés par des risques
professionnels
merci le 1938 monsieur mouillé
lors d'une dernière intervention nous
avons regardé très près la situation des
travailleurs handicapés aujourd'hui il y
a cet homme de mesure existe pour leur
permettre de partir en de façon
anticipée à l'âge de 55 ans car je
devrais pas sur les risques
professionnels sur le le taux de fatigue
aussi des travailleurs handicapés mais
cette situation n'est permis ce que par
décret et ce que je proposerai à cet
amendement c'est que ce soit mis dans la
loi en dur et donc nous puissions le
fixer directement à 55 ans qui est une
véritable avancée et comme j'ai dit tout
à l'heure je suis également la volonté
de simplification du gouvernement pour
la prise à considération de cette
période là voilà l'objet de mon
abonnement merci
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
ces amendements
prenez votre temps
je prends pas
de
j'étais perturbé par madame la
Présidente simplement ces amendements
effectivement portent quelque chose de
d'important là aussi c'est la prise en
compte d'âge d'agents anticipés
la Commission a gardé toujours je le
répète parce que dans ce que l'on va
vous proposer c'est également important
ce principe que les âges anticipés
voulaient dire retraite plus longue donc
si c'est une retraite qui est plus
longue par rapport à la prise en compte
de l'usure ça veut dire qu'il y a eu des
facteurs d'usure ou des facteurs de vie
très particulier on pense notamment à
l'invalidité la maladie qui font en
sorte que il est tout à fait légitime
que la société consacre un effort
supplémentaire tant sur le plan des des
mesures que sur le plan financier à ces
personnes qui ont un parcours un peu
compliqué du fait de certains facteurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y a un
certain nombre d'âge dé par rapport à
cet âge légal proposé à 64 ans mais
comme vous voyez ça fait beaucoup d'âge
on arrive à 55 ans et c'est d'ailleurs
l'âge actuel pour les personnes en
situation de handicap qui ont une durée
d'exposition dont on reparlera
éventuellement tout à l'heure dans ce
handicap par rapport maintenant un
critère nouveau qui sont les critères de
trimestre cotisés ou réputés cotisés
mais pas l'ensemble des trimestres
validés ce qui est un dispositif
d'ouverture par rapport à cet âge et
effectivement on peut comprendre que
certains amendements veuille inscrire
cet âge de 55 ans moyennant des critères
qui sont définis et fixes dans la loi il
y a l'âge également par exemple de 60
ans en ce qui concerne ou 62 ans on va
parler de ces deux P ou actuellement le
C2P c'est vous pouvez bénéficier de deux
ans avec le nombre de points qui vous a
donné des trimestres qui vous permettent
de partir de façon anticipée trop de
personnes prennent ce dispositif par
rapport à d'autres dispositifs et en
conséquence nous avons pensé il était
plus judicieux non pas de les laisser à
62 à 60 ans comme aujourd'hui puisque
deux ans moins l'âge légal ce qui les
laisserait dans le dispositif
d'exposition à certains risques mais
plutôt d'essayer de favoriser le temps
partiel rémunéré de façon complète en
déplafonnant les points vous le verrez
en vous le présentera le moment venu en
développe plafonnant les points
consacrés à ce temps partiel pour qu'on
les réserve pour la fin de carrière ce
serait un peu plus ça nous paraît
maintenant c'est discutable bien entendu
c'est ouvert la discussion ça nous
paraît judicieux de faire une transition
comme ça à travers le C2P en fin de
carrière pour finir de façon progressive
il y a également l'âge de 60 ans en ce
qui concerne l'invalidité l'inaptitude
c'est le droit actuel le gouvernement
propose de le mettre en agent anticipé
par rapport à 64 ceux qui veut dire que
on reste dans le droit actuel et dessus
à nous apparu effectivement par rapport
à ceux qui ont des invalidités des in
études au travail pour aider raison
médicale mais pas pour des raisons
professionnelles de le laisser à 62 ans
ceux qui par contre et c'est là qu'on a
une différence avec le gouvernement qui
sont dans l'incapacité permanente à au
moins 20% ou bien pour ceux qui sont
entre 10 et 20% selon un nombre
d'expositions 17 années d'exposer à
certains risques nous avons une
divergence avec Monsieur le Ministre
parce que nous pensons qu'il ne faut pas
décaler plus pour eux ce passage de 60 à
62 ans et nous souhaitons que maintenir
à 60 ans cette âge pour retraite
anticipée pour invalidité compte tenu
des critères exposés et puis il y aura
on le verra tout à l'heure mais ça fera
partie de notre lourd encore quatre h de
bornes proposées ou trois ou quatre mais
on verra le moment venu pour les
carrières longues et puis il y a toutes
les bornes qu'il y a concernant les
actifs les sédentaires c'est pour ça
qu'on essaye de faire en sorte que ces
personnes là puissent avoir un
relativement équivalent d'un métier à
l'autre ou d'un statut à l'autre qui
sont les bornes qui passent à 59 ans
notamment pour les actifs et 54 ans pour
les super actifs voilà un peu donc notre
raisonnement a été toujours le même et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je donne
un avis défavorable par rapport aux
propositions qui sont faites
puisqu'elles vont à l'encontre de ce que
vous propose votre commission des
affaires sociales merci en ce qui
concerne j'ai dû oublier un amendement
ou deux d'explications
ça c'est vu qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
c'est vu je l'ai expliqué donc c'est le
maintien pour les amendements de 1846 à
433 le maintien du C2P donc comme je
voulais exposé et puis il y a une petite
différence où j'anticipe par rapport à
la réaction de madame ponsémont je sais
ce qui est concerne l'inscription à 55
ans on choisira l'amendement de Philippe
mouillé
je l'attendais je l'attendais non pas
par gentillesse ou pas mais c'est parce
que il faudrait rectifier le vôtre par
rapport à ce qui est proposé c'est pour
ça que nous préférons l'amendement
1938 qui a inscrit bien le dispositif
parce qu'actuellement c'est un décret
donc on inscrit bien par contre il y a
effectivement une petite erreur et ce
qui fait que j'ai donné un avis
défavorable mais c'est le même esprit et
puis également en ce qui concerne le 417
pour Monsieur benaro J'ai un petit
commentaire particulier parce que je
pense que l'auteur de cet amendement n'a
pas bien considéré ce qu'il proposait et
je ne peux pas croire qu'il s'agisse de
son intention parce qu'effectivement
entre l'objet et la volonté il y a une
large différence donc avis défavorable
merci
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente peut-être un
avis en trois points sur le fond mais
sur le rapporteur a dit
l'essentiel des arguments que le
Gouvernement partage simplement préciser
que le gouvernement donne un avis de
sagesse à la mandement 21-26 de monsieur
le rapporteur un avis défavorable ou une
demande de retrait sur tous les autres
amendements puisque la plupart d'entre
eux comme la dimension le rapporteur
sont en réalité satisfait puisque
beaucoup des situations évoquées sont
des situations qui n'évoluent pas avec
le texte que nous vous présentons je
n'ai qu'une différence d'appréciation
avec monsieur le rapporteur qui concerne
l'amendement
1938 pardon je les ai mal de Monsieur
mouillé
l'idée là il nous la partageons puisque
nous souhaitons que le départ des
personnes en situation de handicap soit
fixées reste fixé à 55 ans l'article
351-3 que vous mentionnez dans votre
amendement précise que cet âge de départ
anticipé est fixé par des craies et
précise que
cette et il est actuellement fixé donc à
55 ans le Gouvernement n'envisage
absolument pas de modifier le décret
puisque nous voulons laisser 55 ans ce
que nous ce que je crains ce que nous
craignons c'est la rédaction que vous
proposez disons au maximum 9 ans empêche
finalement qui que ce soit d'aller plus
loin par décret ça peut être un choix
mais en l'état de la rédaction du décret
et la possibilité
ultérieure de la bouger nous
considérions c'était satisfait c'est la
raison pour laquelle c'était plutôt une
demande de retrait qu'un avis qu'un avis
favorable
merci sur ces amendements étaient des
explications de vote
madame nous revenons ici en salle des
conférences la salle qui joue que c'est
l'hémicycle ou se tiennent tous ces
débats sur la réforme des retraites car
j'accueille ici Bernard Chaumier bonjour
vous êtes sénateur à parenté PS de Paris
un mot sur et bien ce qui s'est passé
dans l'hémicycle un peu plus tôt cette
amendement venu de du rapporteur René
Paul Savary sur la surcotte pour les
femmes ayant eu au moins un enfant et
qui vient compenser selon la droite en
tout cas une partie de la réforme des
retraites et de ses effets délétères
pour les femmes une partie de
l'hémicycle la beauté vous qu'est-ce que
vous avez fait vous savez quand vous
avez une réforme comme ça qui fait des
femmes les grandes perdantes le
président Bruno retaillod du groupe les
républicains la redit dans l'hémicycle
et tout le monde le sait les femmes sont
les grandes perdantes et que derrière
vous aviez vous avez un amendement qui
vient compenser en partie mais en partie
seulement le rapporteur le reconnaît
offerte pour les femmes un élu il a le
choix entre deux choses de dire de toute
façon cette réforme est mauvaise et je
vote NON à tout ou de dire ce qui est au
moins atténue les dégâts pour les femmes
je vote pour donc moi à titre personnel
j'ai voté pour mais ça ne se nait en
aucun cas un blanc ça ou un accord sur
cette réforme c'est seulement de dire
puisque si elle risque de passer ce qui
n'est pas certain et bien qu'au moins on
limite un minimum les dégâts pour une
partie des femmes puisque vous l'avez
dit il concerne que les maires cet amant
cet amendement ce qui est quand même
bizarre de mêler la politique nataliste
à une réforme des retraites oui on a
entendu des sénatrices de gauche
rappeler les écarts de salaire notamment
la présidente sont signal 35% des cas de
salaire en moyenne entre les hommes et
les femmes et on a entendu aussi
Laurence Cohen qui est voilà très active
à la mission aussi pour l'égalité de
droit des femmes ici au Sénat dire que
il y avait les carrières chez les petits
salaires qui touchaient les femmes c'est
au final quelque chose quelque chose qui
compense mais uniquement une partie de
la population qui est bien subi ces
écarts de salaire oui puisque
l'amendement ne concerne que les mères
donc par définition ce n'est pas le fait
d'être femme qui qui va compenser c'est
la maternité et donc c'est une drôle
quand même de conception de la loi on
nous a reproché de ne pas prêter assez
attention à l'égalité devant la loi je
constate que là l'ensemble des femmes va
être pénalisée et durement et une partie
seulement en gros on demande aux femmes
de faire des enfants donc ça s'appelle
une politique nataliste pourquoi pas
mais ça se discute dans une loi sur la
famille et sur la politique nataliste ça
n'avait un peu rien à faire là je trouve
que vous voyez il y a une volonté comme
il y a une conscience de la majorité
sanatoriale que ce projet de loi emporte
des tas de conséquences négatives pour
beaucoup de personnes dans la population
les femmes les plus précaires les
métiers pénibles ils essaient de poser
des un peu partout
nous avons invité aussi parce que on a
entendu votre argumentaire dans
l'hémicycle un peu plus tôt dans la
journée vous avez fait remarqué que
certains sénateurs de la majorité de la
droite et du centre avaient demandé à
changer leur vote au lendemain de cette
adoption de l'article 7 celui sur la
mesure d'âge alors certes ne concerne
que quelques sénateurs et cela ne
changera pas l'issue du vote qui a eu
lieu hier et qui a entériné l'adoption
cet article mais vous l'avez noté avec
insistance cela parce que c'est quand
même un fait majeur déjà le report à 64
ans a été votée sans les voies d'une
quarantaine de collègues de la droite
des républicains ou du centre qui ont
préféré s'abstenir ou voter contre ce
qui déjà est déjà hier il y avait eu à
la suite de ce vote on apprend
successivement que 3 puis 5 c'est à dire
qu'à 8 collègues changent leur vote et
ne veulent plus voter pour je crois que
ça se réduit quelque chose d'abord que
c'est que les débats qu'on mène dans
même s'il déplaise aurait républicains
et ben les arguments que l'on porte
finissent par être entendu par un
certain nombre de collègues et la
deuxième pointe et qui est très que je
salue c'est que nous avons des collègues
qui écoutent aussi ce que dit le peuple
qui sont retournés dans leur département
ou qui ont discuté avec des citoyens
dans leur département qui leur ont dit
que ça n'était pas possible de voter
cette réforme il change leur vote il
faut noter que maintenant il y a moins
de 200 voix pour au Sénat c'est tout à
fait inédit et ça rend très aléatoire la
poursuite de la réforme qu'est-ce que ça
dit il nous reste un peu moins d'une
minute pour pour finir quelques
questions mais qu'est-ce que ça dit de
ce qui pourrait se passer si on allait
jusqu'à l'article 20 et l'ensemble du
texte est-ce que vous croyez qu'il y
aurait une majorité à droite et au
centre pour vanter voter l'ensemble de
du texte j'en sais rien chacun prendra
ses responsabilités on verra bien mais
je veux souligner que à l'issue du vote
au Sénat qui déjà montre une majorité
très affaiblie autour de cette réforme
de retraite il faudra que l'Assemblée
nationale
la valide et il est probable que le
gouvernement doit viser du 49-3 merci
merci Bernard jaumier pour cette
réaction au micro le public c'est là
nous on retourne dans l'hémicycle pour
suivre ses débats en direct
7433 qui ont reçu un double avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre qui abstient et ne sont
pas adoptés et enfin le 19 38 qui a reçu
un avis favorable de la commission une
demande de retrait du gouvernement qui
est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
je sais pas si c'est 18 amendements
maintenant en discussion commune
commençant avec le 43 34 kit défend
madame Cohen
merci madame la Présidente le
Gouvernement présente la création d'un
dispositif carrière super longue et le
statu quo concernant le dispositif
carrière longue existant comme des
mesures de justice sociale or les
dispositifs carrière longues ne seront
pas renforcés en réalité l'âge de départ
pour les bénéficiaires de carrière
longue qui ont commencé à travailler à
18 ou 19 ans sera allongée de deux ans
soit un départ à 62 ans en 2030 et ce
ayant commencé avant 18 ans pourront
toujours partir à 60 ans mais il
connaîtront un durcissement de leur
situation puisqu'ils devront s'acquitter
de la durée de cotisation majorée d'un
an c'est un véritable en fait coup de
communication le gouvernement maintient
58 ans l'âge de départ pour celles et
ceux ayant commencé à travailler avant
16 ans soit moins mes chers collègues de
1% des générations qui sont touchées par
la réforme en effet pour la génération
1973 le dis tentative de carrière super
longue ne concerne
pas plus que 300 personnes par an
environ et là j'ai moyen d'accès un
premier emploi stable et passer de 20
ans en 2060 en
1975 pardon à 27 ans aujourd'hui du coup
notre amendement vise à supprimer les
trois bornes d'âge de départ anticipé
pour les carrières longues et très
longue merci Madame ponce pour le 36 68
merci madame la Présidente alors
vous renvoyez un décret la définition
des âges anticipés des départs anticipés
pour carrière longue et des conditions
de durée requises dans le texte proposé
la seule référence au dispositif
envisagé et dans le fait de remplacer je
cite les assurés qui ont commencé leur
activité avant un âge etc etc
par les assurés qui ont commencé leur
activité avant un des trois âges
sous-entendus 16-18 et 20 cette
modification n'apporte rien à l'état du
droit puisqu'il y avec la rédaction
actuelle il existe déjà quatre rages 16
17 18 et 20 ans pire la modification
envisagée vient figer elle vient figer
des possibilités du pouvoir
réglementaire en matière d'âge alors
qu'il s'agit au contraire d'un paramètre
sur lequel il faut trouver le plus de
souplesse possible au profit ici de la
durée d'assurance requise actuellement
le décret dispose que les assurés ayant
commencé à travailler avant 20 ans
doivent justifier d'une durée de
cotisation équivalente à celle requise
pour le taux plein les assurés ayant
commencé à travailler avant 16 ans
doivent justifier de cette durée mais
majorée de 8 trimestres le gouvernement
dans son dossier de presse prévoit
d'abaisser cette condition à quatre
trimestres
avant 16 ans de majorer cette durée de 4
trimestres pour ceux ayant commencé
avant 18 ans et ne prévoit pas de la
majorité comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
pour les assurer ils ont commencé avant
20 ans c'est très compliqué hein nous
vous proposons donc de modifier les
dispositions envisagées c'est la
conséquence et de supprimer à chaque
fois la référence aux trois âges vous
voyez la complexité qu'on en parle et de
les remplacer par une disposition claire
précisant les conditions de durée
requises en précisant que la durée de
cotisation requise pour l'anticipation
au titre de la carrière longue est égal
à la durée d'assurance requise pour le
taux plein c'est bien plus simple vous
en conviendrez merci Madame madame Lubin
pour le 26 35
merci madame la Présidente moi je vais
pas relire le motif parce que enfin
l'objet parce que c'est exactement le
même que celui de ma collègue Raymond de
pensée mange donc je vais poser le
problème
ce projet de loi amène à avoir des âges
extrêmement différents en matière de fin
des durées différentes en matière de
carrière longue alors il y aura il y a
une dispositif pour ceux qui auront
commencé à travailler avant 16 ans
certes c'est bien il existait déjà un
certain nombre de choses bon ça
concernera très peu de gens au final
mais ça aura le mérite d'exister
aujourd'hui les gens qui ont commencé
qui ont cotisé 5 trimestres
avant 20 ans et qui ont le nombre de
trimestres requis à l'âge requis peuvent
prétendre à une carrière longue des 60
ans bon cela qui vont constituer qui
constituent déjà et qui constitueront
encore plus dans les 10 années qui
viennent le gros de la cohorte des
carrières longues cela vont devoir
continuer à travailler jusqu'à 62 ans
alors certes c'est un peu le débat qu'on
avait tout à l'heure pour eux 62 ans ça
sera mieux que 64 mais c'est pire que 60
on est bien d'accord
et pour la plupart ce sont des gens
qui travaillent déjà on l'a dit depuis
longtemps puis ce sont ceux-là que l'on
retrouve dans tous les métiers dont on
n'arrête pas de parler voilà donc moi
j'amène tout le monde à réfléchir quand
même pour un certain nombre de ces
personnes là
deux ans de plus lorsque la loi sera
totalement vigueur ou quelques mois à
partir de maintenant ça n'est pas rien
donc effectivement nous ce que nous
préconisons c'est 43 ans de cotisations
et on s'en va
merci nous allons maintenant trois
amendements identiques le 45 monsieur
Cabanel merci madame la Présidente le
dispositif de retraite anticipée pour
carrière longue a été mis en place en
2023 pardon dans un esprit de justice
sociale pour accompagner les réformes
d'un logement de la durée d'assurance
requise les assurés qui ont commencé à
travailler particulièrement tôt et qui
remplissent certaines conditions de
durée d'assurance peuvent ainsi
bénéficier d'un départ en retraite
anticipé pour carrière longue afin
d'amortir l'impact du relèvement de
l'âge légal sur les assurés qui ont
travaillé le plus tôt l'article 8
modifie les conditions apicales aux
carrières longues l'âge de départ à la
retraite pour longue carrière serait
ainsi anticipé selon trois bornes d'âge
c'est amendement propose de créer une
quatrième borne d'âge de début
d'activité permettant un départ anticipé
pour les assurer ayant travaillé avant
21 ans cette nouvelle borne d'âge
permettra aux assurer et en réuni quatre
si un trimestre avant 21 ans et
justifiant de leur durée d'assurance
requise cotisée de partir à l'âge de 63
ans les âges de début d'activité et
l'âge de départ possible sont définies
par décret un décret précisera par
ailleurs que pour l'ensemble des niveaux
de dispositif carrière longue la
condition de durée cotisée sera fixée
conformément à la durée d'assurance
requise pour le droit commun ainsi
assurer pourra partir à la retraite à
taux plein si la cotisée au moins cette
durée dès que l'or qu'il aura atteint
l'âge anticipé de départ au titre des
carrières longues
merci Présidente c'est amendement
présenté par mon collègue Xavier
yakovelli et notre groupe est exactement
le même que celui qui a été excellenté
par notre collègue Cabanel donc je n'en
dirai pas plus très bien nous avons
maintenant le 3407
identique madame ponce
oui il est identique mais je tiens à
ressouler effectivement et ça va être
souvent le cas que nous cet amendement
les sénateurs du groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire souhaite atténuer
la brutalité de la réforme portée par le
gouvernement effectivement l'article 8
précise que l'âge de départ à la
retraite pour longue carrière peut être
anticipée selon trois bandages vous avez
vu quand même proposer d'autres
formulations donc je continue au cas où
l'amendement précédent ne sera pas
retenu qui sont définis par décret
l'accès au dispositif est en effet
conditionné un début d'activité 16 18 20
ans le président amendement a pour objet
malheureusement vu cette complexité de
créer une possibilité de départ anticipé
pour les assurer ayant travaillé avant
21 ans en créant une quatrième borne
d'âge de début d'activité
c'est conformément aux annonces c'est de
la première ministre du 5 février 2023
conformément à cet engagement à décret
précisera également que pour l'ensemble
des niveaux de dispositifs carrière
longue et c'est ça qui est important la
condition de durée cotisée sera fixée
conformément à la durée d'assurance
requise pour le droit commun aujourd'hui
quoi qu'on en pense c'est 43 à nuités au
terme de l'accélération du calendrier
Touraine dès lors qu'il atteint la
j'anticiper le départ au titre des
carrières longues l'assuré devra pouvoir
partir à la retraite à taux plein Steve
a cotiser au moins cette durée requise
merci merci pour le suivant le 208
monsieur mandoline
il est défendu le 43 36
qui le défend
ces messieurs ça veulent des
ça va être monsieur saveldi merci madame
la Présidente
aujourd'hui pour accéder à la retraite
anticipée pour handicap à 55 ans il faut
remplir deux conditions cumulatives à la
fois validé une certaine durée
d'assurance trimestre utilisée puisse
trimestre assimilé dont un certain
nombre de trimestres cotisés et là la
réforme propose de ne plus retenir que
la cotisation de la condition de curer
cotisée cela réduit certes la durée
totale d'assurance pour bénéficier du
dispositif mais à nos yeux cela ne rend
rien à programmer problématique la durée
de cotisation reste beaucoup trop longue
pire cela
risque de rendre encore plus compliqué
l'accès aux dispositif car les
trimestres assimilés mais non cotisés
notamment au titre du chômage d'un arrêt
de maladie d'un stage etc ne sont plus
plis en compte d'ailleurs ce retour en
arrière en totalement en contradiction
avec l'article qui prévoit de mieux
prendre en compte les périodes de stage
de formation professionnelle donc on
peut être favorable à la réduction de la
durée d'assurance totale exigée mais il
est inacceptable de supprimer la prise
en compte des trimestres validés il faut
maintenir donc cette possibilité de
prendre en compte les trimestres valides
assimilés et élargir les périodes
reconnues comme telles que soient les
pertes de chômage d'arrêt maladie
accident du travail période de stage de
formation professionnelle perte
d'apprentissage période de service
civique etc il faut également réduire la
durée exigée de cotisations situation
d'handicap d'au moins 20 trimestres car
une personne en situation de handicap
ayant passé plus de 5 années au chômage
ou en maladie ne pourra pas prétendre à
une retraite anticipée en remplissant
les autres conditions c'est vous dire
que cet amendement n'est pas abonnement
seulement de notre groupe c'est nous ne
l'avons déposé avec l'esprit de ce que
nous a demandé de mettre ici en débat
qui a été réalisé par le collectif
handicap qui correspond et qui rassemble
52 organisations plan national sur cet
enjeu de la question du handicap donc il
faudrait faire bénéficier les personnes
dont le handicap survient à compter de
40 ans et qui ont un taux d'incapacité
supérieur à 50%, merci monsieur le
ministre le 46 51
l'article 8 prévoit la prise en compte
des trimestres aquiotiques de
l'assurance vieillesse parents au foyer
et de l'assurance vieillesse des aidants
pour calculer le bénéfice de la retraite
anticipée pour carrière longue par
dérogation en principe qui fixe les
trimestres cotisées par l'assurés sont
prises en compte dans la rédaction
retenue à l'Assemblée nationale seuls
les trimestres prises en compte
le seul trimestre en compte pardon sont
ceux au cours desquels les intérêts ont
été affiliés au régime général or les
périodes de cours desquelles les assurés
étant aidons étaient aidons et aux
parents au foyer peuvent être fait au
titre de la cnrsl ou au titre de la
cpcmr et donc nous proposons d'élargir
aux autres régimes la prise en compte
des trimestres d'assurance vieillesse
par employés et d'assurance vieillesse
des aidants pour la prise en compte des
trimestres dans le calcul de
l'éligibilité au départ anticipé pour
carrière longue
monsieur le rapporteur l'amendement ou
madame
monsieur rapporteur un moment de la
commission merci c'est une la correction
d'une erreur est actionnaire
pensez mon jeu 35 80
[Musique]
une femme devrait
finalement travailler quasiment jusqu'à
67 ans
d'avoir cette surcote ça permet dans la
dernière année
de pouvoir avoir ce petit plus par
trimestre c'est bien sûr alors certains
vont dire encourager natalité
si vous voulez c'est aussi parce que les
carrracher alors bien évidemment qu'elle
peut être due aussi malheureusement à
des périodes de chômage ou de
difficultés psychologiques ou familiales
dans sa vie mais elles sont quand même
en grande majorité dû aux coupures dû au
grossesse et à des complications liées à
la vie familiale ça a beaucoup changé
maintenant que la nouvelle génération ou
les pairs avec les congés parentaux en
prennent leur part mais on parle encore
d'une génération où c'était vraiment
très majoritairement les femmes qui du
coup à cause de grâce je préfère dire ça
alors vie de famille ont eu ces
carrracher donc c'est une façon quand
même aussi de rendre hommage vous pensez
que cela améliore la réforme
suffisamment par rapport à tout ce que
les femmes peuvent perdre par ailleurs
avec cette réforme des retraite non bien
évidemment ça ne sera jamais assez moi
j'avais moi-même déposé un amendement
demandant à ce que on puisse en effet
pour les femmes partir plutôt à 62 ans
mais
on nous demande à tous de faire des
efforts et je pense et ça a été dit même
sur les bancs également de l'opposition
sénatoriale
ça n'est que la conséquence de
des disparités encore salariales qu'on
peut avoir effectivement pour les
salaires 35% des cas entre les hommes et
les femmes
hier matin pour quelques membres de la
délégation aux droits des femmes et ce
sujet on en a beaucoup parlé notamment
l'indice Pénicaud du renforcement en
fait des sanctions par rapport aux
entreprises qui bien évidemment
ne n'appliquerait pas cette égalité
salariale et donc moi c'est des sujets
sur lesquels je j'essaye de travailler
beaucoup au sein de la délégation alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle vous a répondu
Isabelle borne puisque vous l'avez vu
hier et que vous nous la prenez à ce
micro est-ce qu'elle est-ce qu'elle vous
a dit réfléchir de nouvelles trains de
mesures sur ces différents salariales ou
ces inégalités oui justement on a on a
parlé en effet du fait qu'elle allait
renforcée c'est l'index
mais on a aussi parlé des quelque chose
qui me tient particulièrement à coeur
des
de tous les le
excusez-moi c'est la fatigue des nuits
les
secteurs de du numérique notamment et
scientifique mais surtout numérique pour
essayer de renforcer l'attractivité
vis-à-vis des femmes dans ces
secteurs-là donc voilà on a au-delà
également d'un renforcement mais ça je
veux pas dévoiler dans leur plan égalité
homme-femme
d'une amélioration aussi de certains
certaines choses se concernant les
violences faites aux femmes qui restent
bien évidemment un sujet
très important pour délégation pour
notre sujet qui touche finalement en
retraite moi je dis surtout en effet
qu'on a besoin peut-être une grand texte
sur l'emploi où là on pourrait revenir
bien évidemment sur les disparités
hommes femmes pardon et qu'on puisse
revaloriser bien évidemment le travail
des femmes j'ai une dernière question
cela concerne les coupures de courant
qui ont pu concerner certaines
circonscriptions où il y a des bureaux
de sénateurs leur bureau leur bureau où
ils accueillent leur concitoyens
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
coupures on a entendu Bruno Retailleau
les dénoncer dans l'hémicycle un peu
plus tôt dans la journée oui c'est
absolument scandaleux alors bien
évidemment c'est pas du tout
c'est pas son panneaux nos amis
parlementaires qui qui sont derrière
tout ça simplement je trouve ça
proprement scandaleux scandaleux nous
prendre en otage et pendant même son
temps de parole donc Bruno Retailleau
parlait lui-même il avait la propre
coupure dans son quartier dans le
quartier de de sa permanence en Vendée
et puis surtout on a appris que
autour de la permanence de Gérard
Larcher dans les Yvelines à Rambouillet
du coup une clinique a été plongée dans
le noir le temps que bien évidemment en
effet on puisse y mettre j'imagine les
tous les les
générateurs et ça ça perturbé les
services tout ça est dramatique début
janvier un quartier de Massy dans mon
département d'Essonne avait été plongé
dans le noir entre 6h et 8h du matin je
pense que les grévistes pensaient que
c'était un quartier des affaires alors
que c'était un quartier d'habitation et
ça du gênait quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de Sonia c'est donc que il y
avait des répercussions de de ce débat
c'est que voilà on voit l'importance
aussi de ce qui se joue dans l'hémicycle
depuis 10 jours vous le dites aussi oui
je le dis d'autant plus que et ça j'en
suis assez fier et je partage avec
l'ensemble de l'hémicycle beaucoup
beaucoup de Français nos concitoyens
nous ont dit qu'ils attendaient aussi de
nous de redorer le blason en fait du
Parlement et de la politique en général
moi j'étais absolument atterrée des
spectacles du spectacle qui avait donné
l'Assemblée nationale et je me disais
qu'en effet il fallait pas s'étonner
après que les gens n'aillent plus voter
et du coup je pense que on était
d'autant plus attendus et peut-être par
curiosité au-delà même du du sujet des
retraites qui est bien sûr fondamental
je pense que les gens étaient intéressés
de voir peut-être la différence de de
façon de de pouvoir échanger même si je
dois dire que depuis 6 ans je n'ai
jamais assisté à des débats aussi
musclés
on va le dire comme cela s'est tendu
effectivement notamment depuis 48 heures
autour d'article 7 effectivement on a pu
vivre tout ça sur l'antenne de publics
là merci learcos merci d'être venu à ce
micro nous on retourne dans l'hémicycle
pour écouter René Paul Savary merci
proposons de partir avant à la retraite
pour qu'il bénéficie à peu près voilà
c'est purement théorique à peu près de
même temps de retraite que quelqu'un qui
a eu une carrière plus facile alors pour
faire cela prendre en compte
il est un dispositif l'ex législatif la
loi numéro
l351-1 qui dit que l'ensemble de ces
dispositifs les bornes d'âge et la durée
sont prises par décret voilà Quentin
pris par décret donc si vous voulez
après on peut parler de 43 ans d'annuité
on peut parler de deux trois quatre
bornes de tâches
la loi je vais y arriver mille excuses
dit bien que c'est un âge fixé par
décret et une durée fixée par décret et
quand vous ramenez ça dans ces
dispositifs vous mettez des bornes et
des durées et bien effectivement
il y a des conséquences qui sont pas
forcément la même et vous ne pouvez pas
dans le dispositif actuel dire il y aura
tel durée pour telle pour ces personnes
là parce que selon l'âge selon les mois
de naissance vous avez une répercussions
différentes et vous rentrez où vous
rentrez pas dans le dispositif et que
les 43 ans puisque ces deux ça qu'il
s'agit aujourd'hui c'est une durée de
cotisation plancher ce n'est pas une
durée de cotisation plafond les 64 ans
âge légal c'est un âge minimal de départ
en retraite ce n'est pas un plafond
c'est la même Ginette d'esprit qu'il
faut faire pour comprendre le dispositif
mais ce serait tôt simple ni l'excuses
là aussi c'est pour ça que je suis vous
l'avez compris avec une position qui est
pas toujours en accord avec celle de
Monsieur le Ministre mais il partage les
principes de mes propositions je prends
5 minutes pour les exposer oui mais
c'est parce que c'est un travail déjà de
longue haleine là-dessus de très longues
haleine je me permets de les exposer
mais vous me ferez moi j'ai pas réussi
j'ai pas réussi à faire une
contre-proposition c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai donné la Commission à
donner un avis de sagesse j'ai pas
réussi à faire une contrepoose positive
simplement vous prenez pour ces
carrières longues dans la loi c'est
marqué que c'est 4 à 5 trimestres avant
votre année anniversaire la fin de
l'année celui qui a trois trimestres il
est pas dans le dispositif c'est la
borne suivant et quatre as un trimestre
à la fin c'est pas facile à expliquer
parce que pour les autres dispositifs
communs vous partez quand vous avez
telle durée quel que soit votre date de
naissance vous avez 43 ans de cotisation
et bien vous partez à la retraite c'est
pas avoir catastrophe avant le début et
puis ensuite
ce serait trop simple il y a le
dispositif de la durée quand vous
calculez la durée de ces dispositifs
43 ans
qui sont affectés à une borne durée de
cotisations plus de c'est la réforme
Touraine sur la bosse de la borne de ces
ans c'est durée de cotisation plus de 43
+ 2
= 45 ans quand vous appliquez cette
durée de cotisation et que vous comptez
les trimestres ce ne sont pas les mêmes
trimestres comptés que pour le régime
général d'un côté entre en compte que
les trimestres cotisées c'est à dire
qu'il y avait véritablement les gens qui
ont travaillé concrétisé ou réputés
cotisés parce qu'il y a une petite marge
de solidarité de l'autre côté on a un
système très solidaire qui permet de
prendre en compte certes les années
cotisées mais également quand vous avez
été malade des indemnités journalières
le chômage des réputés cositisés et des
assimilés et des majorations notamment
on en a parlé tout à l'heure qui fait
que dans les 43 ans il y a pas forcément
43 ans de travail il y a aussi 43 ans
qui sont compensés au titre de la
solidarité c'est un régime très
solidaire cette solidarité dans le
régime dégénéral ne s'applique pas au
régime des carrières longues ce qui fait
que quand on décline le dispositif vous
avez quelqu'un qui part à 20 ans puisque
c'est une nouvelle bonne vingt ans
voyez-vous quand il a ces quatre cent
trimestre avant la fin d'anniversaire de
sa 20e année quand il est dans un
dispositif où il a fait une grande école
par exemple
rémunérer et bien rentre dans le
dispositif et il va partir à 63 ans
c'est la proposition parce qu'il a
Polytechnique par exemple l'école des
impôts deuxième exemple donc il va
rentrer et le bien portant qu'à une part
guerrière sûrement difficile parce que
c'est sûrement difficile
partira 63 ans celui qui est dans les
mêmes conditions mais qui fait une autre
école qui est pas ou qui est rémuné ou
qui va dans sa carrière il est dans les
mêmes dispositions et à ses 4 à 5 ans
avant il arrive lui il a été malade il a
continué à travailler il a eu un entrain
de d'indemnité journalière il a repris
le boulot il a eu un amitié journalière
et ben celui-là comme on compte pas les
trimestres de la même façon et ben il
part à 64 ans donc voyez-vous pour
partir avec un départ anticipé il faut
être bien portant avec un métier pas
trop difficile pour partir dans les
autres conditions celui qui a un métier
usant et qui peut être malade et ben il
bénéficie pas du dispositif il est nagué
des terres il est illisible parce que
effectivement c'est 4 à 5 ans etc et on
peut toujours mettre des bornes on peut
toujours mettre des amendements sur les
durées de cotisation le dispositif
est-elle que les dispositions se
prennent par décret donc moi j'ai
tendance à donner effectivement et la
commission aussi un avis de sagesse par
rapport à cela parce que vous avez la
possibilité effectivement de trouver le
système le moins inégaléaire possible et
quand on dit 43 ans comme c'était
proposé à mettre sur chacune des bornes
on peut toujours le voter moi j'ai aucun
inconvénient là-dessus sauf que vous
dites pas la vérité aux gens parce que
selon l'âge selon le mois où vous êtes
né dans l'année et bien il y a des gens
qui feront de toute façon
systématiquement 44 ans et vous n'y
pouvez rien c'est les mathématiques qui
s'imposent voilà pourquoi ce système
illisible inégalitaire j'aurais souhaité
monsieur le ministre vous proposer
quelque chose de plus juste qui
n'entendent pas les finances non plus
parce qu'il faut faire attention que
chaque disposition quand vous dites ah
bah c'est facile on va faire que 43 ans
sauf que derrière il y a une addition à
payer et je préfère je préfère quand
même puisque nous avons une réforme
budgétaire où il faut combler des
déficitifs et non pas les creuser je
préfère qu'on consacre plutôt à des
mesures de solidarité les maires de
famille plutôt qu'à ses bornes d'âge
relativement inégalitaire il n'empêche
que certaines dispositions étaient
prises certaines proposition avancée par
madame la Première ministre donc il
incompte bien entendu au gouvernement de
les confirmer mais en attendant je pense
que on peut voter certaines dispositions
par forcément d'autres voilà où je
voulais en venir en sachant que j'avais
encore donc un avis toujours de sagesse
mais vous l'avez compris et je pense que
je donnerai plutôt un avis défavorable
donc sur la durée d'âge parce que
pardon oui la durée d'âge est 43 ans
systématiquement je pense qu'il faut pas
aller dans cette voie là parce qu'on ne
dit pas la vérité aux Français mais
c'est le ministre qui dira comment il
veut faire derrière bien entendu par
contre en ce qui concerne les bornes
d'âge bon qu'il y ait trois ou carbone
on voit bien qu'on peut les régler on
n'est pas obligé de mettre 16 18 20 21
parce que je pense qu'il aurait été plus
simple de mettre de 17 19 21 peu importe
je n'ai pas trouvé la solution vous
l'avez pas trouvé vous m'avez dit mais
sachons nous retrouver peut-être
là-dessus pour dire la vérité et
répondre au problème des personnes ne
ratons pas la cible la cible c'est ce
qu'on commençait tôt et que une carrière
pénible ne ratons pas la cible et puis
j'ai aussi à donner un avis favorable
bien sûr à l'amendement de Monsieur le
Ministre parce que il a élargit la
solidarité à travers les trimestres en
compte par les avpf ou lava et c'est une
mesure qu'on attendait parce qu'il faut
quand même un peu plus de solidarité
dans ce dispositif carrière longue et
j'ai également à vous dire que
l'amendement de la commission
2128 donc celui que je vous ai proposé
a été corrigé pour le rendre compatible
avec les amendements 45 1918 et 3407
c'est bien cela merci pardonnez-moi
d'avoir été trop long mais il va falloir
il fallait un peu expliquer cela
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le rapporteur si j'ai bien
suivi et sans être excessivement
formaliste c'est un avis de sagesse sur
le les trois identiques 45 19 18 et 34
07 et favorable du Gouvernement et
défavorable sur tous les autres merci
monsieur le ministre c'est à vous
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur a été très clair sur le
dispositif carrière long qui est
exact et extrêmement complexe tout le
monde tout le monde a pu le voir je
voudrais simplement commencer par une
deux précisions de méthode à l'attention
de Madame ponce vous avez dit madame la
sénatrice que le gouvernement avait
déposé deux amendements sur les
carrières longues pourraient tout à fait
exact le gouvernement a déposé le mardi
soir de la deuxième semaine de débat un
amendement identique aux amendements 45
1918 et 3407 visant à autoriser la
création d'une quatrième borne d'âge
ensuite à l'occasion du débat du
vendredi a été évoqué les pistes de
travail sur la question de la durée de
cotisation mais aucun amendement n'a été
déposé la deuxième précision que je veux
apporter concerne un propos que vous
avez eu toujours sur la méthode où vous
nous avez dit Madame
puisque c'était déposé dans le cadre du
47 tiréol le gouvernement aurait pu le
mettre dans le texte ce n'est pas le cas
ce n'est pas le cas puisque l'article
47-1 de la Constitution et la loi
organique qui le décline disent que le
gouvernement en cas de d'impossibilité
d'une des assemblée à aller au bout de
l'examen du texte transmet à l'autre
assemblée son projet de loi initiale
auquel il peut ajouter les amendements
de son choix mais à condition que ces
amendements étaient adoptés par
l'Assemblée saisie du texte dans la
mesure où l'amendement déposé le mardi
je parle de l'identique aux 45 1918 et
34 07 était déposé à l'article 8 que
l'Assemblée nationale n'a jamais
examinée n'a pas été adopté et donc le
47 terrain interdit au gouvernement de
le mettre dans le texte qu'il vous a qui
vous a transmis sur les différents
amendements il y a un propos général que
je veux faire avant de donner un avis
pour chacun en essayant d'être aussi
méthodique que la présidente de séance
le souhaite
le premier le point général concerne les
questions de coût puisque les
dispositifs de carrière longue au-delà
de leur complexité de mise en oeuvre
sont des dispositifs qui sont coûteux si
nous retenons un principe qui consiste à
dire toute assuré qui a travaillé au
moins un trimestre avant l'année de ses
21 ans
était ligible carrière longue nous
sommes sur un coup qui est supérieur à 2
milliards d'euros
si nous disons c'est ce que Monsieur
salvo Delhi a proposé il y a un instant
de qui consiste à dire la durée des 43
ans non seulement supplante la question
de l'âge d'ouverture des droits mais en
plus doit intégrer non seulement les
trimestres cotisés mais aussi les
trimestres valides c'est ce qui a été
proposé par Monsieur le Sénateur
salvadelli nous sommes sur un coup à 7
milliards d'euros et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous ne l'avons pas
retenu si nous indiquons que tout assuré
qui a commencé à travailler avant des
bornes d'âge à hauteur de 5 trimestres
mais sans aucune
autre condition que d'atteindre 43 ans
nous sommes sur un coup qui est très
supérieur à un milliard et demi d'euros
et enfin si nous disons c'est ce que
disent les amendements qui arrivent à la
fin de l'allias pardonnez-moi j'en ai
oublié le numéro les trois la maman 3103
et 3126 qui consiste à dire
par rapport à la situation existante où
il y a trois critères cumulatifs le fait
d'avoir tricotisé cinq trimestres avant
une borne d'âge le fait d'avoir atteint
un âge spécifique d'ouverture des droits
et le fait de se dispenser du troisième
critère qui est celui d'une durée de
cotisation nous sommes sur un coup qui
est supérieur à 300 millions d'euros
c'est l'état d'esprit de ce qui avait
été discuté le vendredi en fin
d'après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale et
donc pour ces raisons là j'appelle le
Sénat à faire preuve de beaucoup
d'attention parce que nous avons souvent
évoqué la nécessité de retrouver
l'équilibre budgétaire et donc financier
du système de retraite et l'addition des
mesures votées je pense par exemple à la
mesure extrêmement utile j'ai de
l'analyse favorable concernant la
surcote qui représente elle aussi 300
millions d'euros font que cette
perspective d'équilibre s'éloignerait en
2030 et je pense qu'il serait
extrêmement négatif d'avoir une réforme
qui permet d'améliorer les choses mais
qui ne nous permettent pas d'atteindre
l'équilibre en 2030 pour en venir les
différents avis sur l'amendement 43 34
de madame assassy qui supprime les trois
bornes d'âge la vie est défavorable pour
des raisons budgétaires que je viens
d'évoquer nous serions extrêmement ça
serait extrêmement coûteux pour
l'amendement de Madame poncer mon 36 88
pour les mêmes raisons budgétaires c'est
un avis qui est défavorable pour
l'amendement numéro 26 35 de Madame
Lubin là aussi les raisons budgétaires
que j'ai évoquées nous amène à donner un
avis défavorable et ce d'autant plus que
les différents évolutions et notamment
le fait de fixer une borne d'âge à 21
ans tel que nous le proposons est tel
que je le soutiendrai dans un instant
répondre à très largement à votre
préoccupation pas entièrement mais assez
largement sur les amendements 45 1918 et
34 07 de Monsieur Cabanel yakovelier de
Madame ponce la vie est favorable
puisqu'il s'agit de permettre la
création d'une quatrième borne d'âge et
le gouvernement s'est engagé à créer une
borne d'âge à 21 ans pour l'amendement
208 de Madame Müller Brown il n'a pas
été défendu merci madame la Présidente
pour l'amendement
il a été il est présenté il a été
indiqué Monsieur il a été il est il est
dans le dans le lot il est parti il
n'est pas retiré il n'est pas tombé ça
ne change malheureusement pas la vie des
favorable pour les raisons budgétaires
que j'ai évoqué je ferai attention à
écouter la présidence de sens plutôt que
la présidente de la commission désormais
pour
pour l'amendement 4336 présenté par
Madame assassin c'est une demande de
retrait madame la Présidente assassin
c'est une demande de retrait pour Madame
la présentation sur le 43 36 parce qu'en
fait avec le 43 36 je pense que vous
n'atteignez pas l'objectif que vous
cherchez la disposition telle qu'elle
est dans le projet de loi permet
d'intégrer ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui les trimestres cotisés soit
au titre de l'assurance vieillesse par
en foyer une partie des congés parentaux
soit au titre de la source de
l'assurance vieillesse pour les aidants
d'intégrer ces trimestres dans ce retenu
pour calculer le droit des parents
anticipés carrière longue et je pense
que c'est un progrès je propose avec un
amendement du Gouvernement d'élargir ce
progrès du régime général à tous les
régimes et votre amendement supprimerait
la possibilité de compter ses trimestre
d'aidant ou de parents au foyer dans
l'éligibilité au dispositif carrière
longue donc c'est retrait ou défavorable
l'amendement du Gouvernement c'est
évidemment un avis favorable
l'amendement 21 28 de Monsieur Savary
favorable le 35 80 de Madame ponce
défavorable pour des raisons budgétaires
le 21 29 de Monsieur Savary favorable
l'amendement de
et pardonnez-moi madame la Présidente
c'est la même mécanique donc c'est la
même demande de retrait
l'amendement 21 30 de Monsieur Savary
c'est un avis favorable les amendements
31 03 et 37 26 des messieurs Cabanel est
Chassin sur les questions durée de
cotisation c'est le sens des discussions
que nous avons eu le vendredi à
l'Assemblée nationale avec cette
difficulté budgétaire du coup à 300
millions d'euros et la nécessité je
crois de trouver dans le cadre des
étapes suivantes du débat parlementaire
je pense notamment la commission mixte
paritaire l'équilibre financier donc à
ce stade ne souhaitons pas dégrader les
équilibres financiers du système à la
sortie de l'examen du texte au Sénat
c'est une demande de retrait même si le
débat doit se poursuivre pour
l'amendement de Madame Lubin le 30 99
les raisons budgétaires m'amènent à
donner un avis défavorable et enfin
sur le 33 92 et le 34 08 c'est une
demande de retrait pour les mêmes
raisons que celle que j'ai évoqué il y a
un instant
ce qu'il y a des explications de vote
sur Madame Lubin
tout d'abord monsieur le rapporteur et
Monsieur le Ministre d'ailleurs vous
parlez tout le temps de contraintes
budgétaires c'est bien la preuve on a
déjà dit mais je vais quand même lui
répéter c'est bien la preuve que le
véhicule
législatif n'est pas le bon
non mais non parce que justement on ne
peut pas aborder toutes les questions de
des salariés qui arrivent en fin de
carrière
et qui ont du mal à terminer leur
carrière à ceux qui travaillent depuis
longtemps on ne peut l'aborder que sous
le prisme budgétaire puisqu'on est dans
une loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale or il faudrait aller bien
au-delà vous avez dit d'ailleurs j'ai
noté monsieur le rapporteur vous avez eu
l'expression il ne faut pas rater la
cible et oui nous y voilà parce que la
cible de ce projet de loi c'est bien les
travailleurs de longue durée si si c'est
bien là c'est bien ça le problème ce
projet de loi vous nous avez
suffisamment reproché la réforme
Touraine qui rajoute qui a amené à 43
ans de cotisations à partir de l'année
fallait-il vraiment puisqu'effectivement
tous ceux qui sont nés à partir de
l'année 73 devront travailler 43 ans
fallait-il vraiment aller chercher les
autres qui sont ceux qui travaillent
forcément depuis le plus longtemps donc
vous parlez de rater la cible on est
justement en plein dans la cible et ce
projet de loi ne la rate paste cible
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire
ensuite un détail il faut dire la vérité
donc les 43 ans ça peut effectivement en
fonction du moment où on est né de plus
être 43 mais 44 mais dans le projet de
loi aussi je citer un exemple moi je
suis né en 1963 je vais avoir 62 ans
donc en
je vais avoir 62 ans en 2025 donc il me
faudra après 62 ans et 9 mois sauf que
je suis né en juillet ah dommage donc 62
ans et 9 mois je peux pas les avoir
l'année 2025 je crois que j'attends de
l'année 2026 et donc en fait c'est un an
de plus pour moi c'est pas grave mais
pour mes copines de l'agroalimentaire
qui est viscères à des canards dans les
Landes je peux vous dire c'est pas
marrant du tout
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente alors moi je
rejoins
sur rejoindre la difficulté de monsieur
le rapporteur
a éclairé notre choix
je crois que ce que cela montre c'est la
difficulté effectivement
d'atténuer la brutalité de cette réforme
quoi parce qu'elle est évident que pour
les départs anticipés
qui ont quand même augmenté deux ans de
fait que ce soit pour pénibilité ou que
ce soit pour carrière longue
ça conduisait de tel aberration
travailler 44 45 ans de durée c'est à
dire bien au-delà du taux plein qu'il a
fallu que le gouvernement bricole
quelque chose de super compliqué et qui
d'ailleurs lui permettait de passer la
moitié de son temps d'explication de la
réforme a montré comment sur les
carrières super longues etc il avait
consenti des mesures sociales
et donc effectivement je veux dire toute
cette complexité vous avez dit c'est
illisible cette inégalitaire oui comme
la loi et là ça a tellement soulevé de
mécontentements et d'opposition qu'il a
fallu bricoler bon ben le bricolage si
tout le monde a suivi l'explication de
monsieur le rapporteur général
bravo alors les raisons budgétaires
effectivement les raisons budgétaires le
gouvernement n'accepte d'avoir veut 18
milliards de recettes et n'acceptent
d'avoir que des mesures d'atténuation de
la brutalité de la réforme qu'à hauteur
de 3 milliards et comme il dit que c'est
6 milliards parce qu'il s'est trompé et
il a pas il a cru qu'il avait avancé à
60 ans l'âge d'invalidité permanente et
donc il a chiffré à 3 milliards cette
mesure mais non comme c'était maintenu
ça avait rien à faire là et que le
tableau d'équilibre du coup qui arrive à
zéro en 2030
lui permet de dégager 3 milliards moi
j'ai 3 milliards voilà vous avez des
marges de manœuvre budgétaire et pour
accepter nos amendements vous avez 3
milliards
[Musique]
la parole est au président Retailleau
je voudrais expliquer le vote de notre
groupe sur cette série d'amendements
et je sais parfaitement les réticences
qu'à notre rapporteur qui sont à je
crois c'est partager par la commission
sur ces extensions sur les carrières
longues
nous votre en fait on va les calibrer
avec deux principes premier principe ne
pas faire perdre leur sens à la notion
de carrière longue deuxième principe
faire en sorte que la généralisation
quasi généralisation de la carrière
longue ne mettent pas à mal les
principes généraux de notre système par
répartition premier principe je disais
ne pas faire perdre aux carrière longue
leur sens pourquoi tout simplement parce
que une étude récente l'a montré
désormais il y a au moins la même
espérance vie pour ceux qui en
bénéficient par rapport à ceux qui n'en
bénéficient plus on est plus du tout
dans le système que François Fillon
avait inventé justement pour faire face
à un certain nombre de dispositifs en
2003 première chose la compensation de
la carrière longue pour une moindre
espérance vie ça n'existe plus voilà
donc ça c'est le premier point et
deuxième point on retrouve désormais
pour ceux qui bénéficient des carrières
longues des gens qui ont eu des métiers
peu pénibles avec des niveaux scolaires
conséquents ça n'est plus du tout ce qui
a été inventé le cadre et le dispositif
inventé à l'origine et vous voyez que en
étendant à l'infini des élèves de
Polytechnique qui sont rémunérés et qui
commencent à 20 21 ans pourraient partir
à 63 ans donc là là il y a un premier
problème ce qui veut dire que on
acceptera la borne de 21 et on votera
les articles les amendements là-dessus
en revanche pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'ira
pas jusqu'au 43 invités parce que là je
considère nous considérons que là du
coup la généralisation et l'écrasement
si j'ose dire des des bornes d'âge de la
mesure d'âge par rapport à la nuitée
fait perdre son sens à notre système
actuel le système actuel il repose sur
l'équilibre ou pardon un on a des durées
de cotisation et ensuite on a un filet
de sécurité avec l'âge c'est la raison
pour laquelle et pour être conséquent
pour ne pas trop dépenser financer la
mesure que nous avons voté tout à
l'heure pour les maires de famille on ne
votera pas les amendements à 43 ennemis
très bien est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
explications de vote monsieur
vandrinberg pardon
merci Madame ma présidente j'essaye de
comprendre président Retailleau vient
d'expliquer que on pouvait sortir de
Polytechnique et puis effectivement
bénéficier du système des carrières
longues je ne pense pas que tout le
monde ici est fait Polytechnique pour
comprendre le dispositif des carrières
longues que notre ami collègue René Paul
Savary s'était vertueux à nous
décortiquer mais avoue que c'est pas
simple j'ai bien compris compte tenu
effectivement qui a plusieurs paramètres
qui entrent en ligne de compte que c'est
le renvoie au décret le soin de je
dirais réussir presque une mission
impossible c'est de maintenir une
certaine équité dans ce dispositif or ce
que nous avons demandé nous groupe santé
c'est qu'on lisse un peu le dispositif
alors je sais bien
ça peut avoir un coup
mais la logique la logique voudrait que
quand on part à on commence à 14 ans et
avant
14 ans normalement
l'âge d'ouverture des droits et à 58 ans
ça conduit à travailler au moins 44
années
actuellement c'est 45 donc on peut dire
il y a un progrès vous vous commencez à
15 ans vous pouvez partir à 58 aussi et
là vous pouvez effectivement avoir une
durée de cotisation qui n'est que de 43
ans
à 16 ans vous partez à 60 ans et vous
pouvez avoir une durée de cotisation de
44 ans donc vous voyez je peux continuer
comme ça jusqu'à 21 on a un dispositif
sinusoïdal
qui me paraît oui ou en marche vous
appelez ça comme vous voulez ça serpente
entre 14 et 21 ans avec des durées de
cotisation de 43 ou 44 avouez monsieur
le ministre que c'est pas simple à
comprendre si vous arrivez à convaincre
ici tant mieux en tous les cas je doute
qu'on arrive à convaincre la population
de que ce dispositif est équitable et
effectivement apporte un progrès social
évident merci Monsieur gay
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
heureusement qu'on a pas appliqué
l'article 38 sur l'explication monsieur
le rapporteur ce que même en 10 12
minutes on a été en incapacité de
comprendre en réalité le dispositif qui
nous était proposé et c'est vrai que
c'est dur et on vous a déjà posé la
question hier y compris à monsieur le
ministre c'est ce que vient de dire
notre collègue on ne comprend pas
pourquoi alors qu'il y en a qui vont
partir à 15 qui vont commencer à
travailler à 15 ou à 16 ans ils vont
pouvoir partir au même âge mais celui
qui ou celle qui a commencé à 15 ans va
devoir cotiser une année supplémentaire
par rapport à celui ou celle qui a
commencé à 16 ans et c'est la même chose
pour 17 18 etc et l'inverse il y a un
effet ciseaux qui ne fonctionne pas
parce que nous parlez d'équité d'égalité
bon ben celui ou celle qui a commencé à
15 ans il faut qu'il le parte celui
avant celui ou celle qui a commencé à 16
ou à 17 ans ça nous semble d'une logique
implacable et puis pour répondre
aux présidents au taillot là on parle
des carrières longues moi excusez-moi
peut-être qu'on rencontre pas les mêmes
mais celles et ceux qu'on connaît qui
ont commencé à 15 ou 16 ans c'est pas
tellement celle et ceux qui ont qui font
Polytechnique c'est en général c'est les
ceux qui font de l'apprentissage dans
les carrières sont dures avaient des
métiers difficiles évidemment ils
peuvent évoluer et heureusement mais
souvent ils se retrouvent aussi en fin
de carrière en incapacité et on revient
sur le débat de tout à l'heure ils
finissent une carrière mais pas en
activité et donc cette réforme elle va
doublement les pénaliser à la fin mais
aussi au début de leur carrière donc là
pour le coup si on peut avoir des
précisions et si le monsieur le ministre
peut nous expliquer l'effet de ciseaux
et pour dire surtout que cette mesure
c'est un statu quo et c'est déguisé en
progrès social mais ça ne l'est pas je
vous remercie
monsieur
merci madame la Présidente là j'avoue
très honnêtement
j'ai pas fait Polytechnique et du coup
je n'ai pas tout compris mais je
remercie le rapporteur qui a quand même
éclairé et détaillé un dispositif très
complexe puisqu'il y a des facteurs
multiples dans tous les sens des mesures
d'âge etc bon j'ai bien compris que si
on en restait au texte actuel on générer
quand même des inégalités et d'ailleurs
ça a été souligné dans les débats
ce que certains doivent travailler plus
longtemps j'ai aussi compris une chose
c'est que au fond une ou deux reprises
le rapporteur nous a dit oui ce serait
plus juste mais ça coûte trop cher et
moi j'avoue que j'ai du mal bon d'abord
sans doute parce que je comptais cette
loi mais par ailleurs j'ai du mal à me
dire que nous voulons être juste mais à
condition que ça ne coûte pas trop cher
et là il y a j'avais d'ailleurs cru
comprendre que notre collègue Pradier à
l'Assemblée nationale essayer de dire il
faut pas être juste et puis mettre la
même durée pour tout le monde donc moi
je vous avoue n'ayant pas tout compris
je l'admets comprenant quand même comme
l'a dit mon collègue Fabien gay que ceux
qui commencent à travailler à 15 ans ou
à 16 ans c'est rarement ce qu'on fait
politique technique il y a peut-être un
surdoué qui a commencé politique à 16
ans mais enfin ça doit être assez rare
par contre c'est plutôt des gens qui
rendent des jeunes qui sont rentrés dans
l'apprentissage et dans des métiers
difficiles bah moi j'avoue que je
préfère la justice à l'équilibre
financier dans une loi juste donc je
voterai les amendements qui défendent 43
ans pour tout le monde monsieur le
ministre
[Applaudissements]
mais merci madame la Présidente
peut-être quelques éléments je l'espère
pour éclairer le débat d'abord de dire
en souriant à Madame Lubin mais vous
avez dit Madame Lubin c'est dommage nous
sommes dans un pellet FSR donc ça donne
une connotation budgétaire je peux vous
assurer je veux manger je vous garantis
même que nous si nous étions que si nous
étions dans une un texte de loi de
ordinaire j'aurais le même souci de
l'équilibre budgétaire en 2030 le même
parce que si on ne ré qu'il est pas le
système il ne tiendra pas et le fait
qu'on soit en PLF SS ou en PJL ordinaire
ne change pas l'approche qui est la
mienne ni celle du gouvernement sur
laquelle sur laquelle sur laquelle on
veut fonder l'équilibre ensuite pour à
la fois essayer de répondre à Monsieur
gay et à Monsieur briller à l'instant
sur les carrières longues je l'ai dit au
tout début de notre séance ce matin je
crois lorsque nous avons abordé cet
article 8 aujourd'hui le système c'est
tel qu'il existe prévoit de bornes d'âge
une borne à 16 ans une borne à 20 ans
mais il prévoit surtout trois critères
cumulatifs et un assuré qui a cotisé
cinq trimestres avant 20 ans peut partir
à la retraite deux ans avant l'âge légal
donc aujourd'hui 60 ans mais à condition
d'une part d'avoir les cinq trimestres
cotisées d'autre part d'avoir atteint
effectivement les 60 ans et en plus
d'avoir atteint et d'avoir réuni
aujourd'hui 42 années 168 trimestres
demain 172 trimestres et uniquement des
trimestres cotisés c'est ce qui rend
particulièrement juste la remarque de
monsieur le rapporteur général de
monsieur le rapporteur pardon car
monsieur le rapporteur dit que
finalement celles et ceux qui
bénéficient des carrières longues en
termes de départ anticipé porté à son
maximum d'anticipation sur celles et
ceux qui ont une carrière certes longue
mais particulièrement linéaire sans
exposition à des périodes de chômage
sans exposition des périodes d'arrêt
maladie qui excéderaient quatre
trimestres à l'échelle de leur carrière
et donc finalement ceux qui ont les
derrière les plus difficiles soit
marqués par la précarité soit marqué par
des problèmes de santé on sait que les
deux peuvent être liés sont écartés du
bénéfice effectif des carrières longues
puisque lorsqu'ils arrivent aujourd'hui
à 60 ans ils ne sont pas en capacité de
présenter si je peux dire de juste de
justifier les 158 trimestres pleinement
cotisés c'est pour ça que c'est pas un
effet ciseaux finalement c'est un effet
de perforateur et de mâchonnements parce
que il y a perforation dans la carrière
et il y a machanement de la borne de
départ tellement elle dépend des
situations individuelles et tellement
personne ne peut tracer un trait tout à
fait droit monsieur vanderenberg il a
évoqué aussi il y a un instant en disant
tout ça est un peu sinusoïdal en
fonction de l'âge auquel on commence dès
lors que les bornes d'âge se font deux
ans par deux ans et pas maintenant par
un an votre votre raisonnement monsieur
le sénateur
tiendrai parfaitement dans la seule
hypothèse ou les assurés commenceraient
à travailler le jour de leur
anniversaire parce que s'il ne travaille
pas le jour de leur anniversaire mais
s'il travaille trois mois quatre mois
cinq mois plus tard au rythme d'une
rentrée scolaire au rythme d'une de
l'obtention d'un diplôme
j'allais dire toutes les bornes
n'explosent finalement en tout cas tous
les modalités de calcul explosent et on
arrive à des situations où oui des
assurés vont parfois travailler 44 ans
pour avoir droit à un départ alors que
d'autres seront piles à 43 ans mais la
plupart d'entre eux seront entre 43 ans
et trois mois quatre mois cinq mois en
fonction tout simplement de l'histoire
de leur vie il y a un point sur lequel
je reste invité si vous me le permettez
le Sénat ne pas peut-être porter trop
d'attention en tout cas pas au-delà de
ce qu'il en faut c'est la borne d'âge à
16 ans puisque monsieur le sénateur
vanderenberg là aussi dit ceux qui
veulent ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler à 14 ans doivent pouvoir
partir beaucoup plus tôt et ne pas
nécessairement attendre 58 ans
sauf que ce cas de figure est devenu
extrêmement rare le départ avec mais
j'ai au bout le départ avec cinq
trimestres valides avant 16 ans concerne
entre quelques dizaines et un peu moins
de 200 personnes par an aujourd'hui pour
une raison qui s'explique de manière
évidente c'est que l'obligation de
scolarité a été portée à 16 ans en 1959
ce qui signifie que ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 16 ans
dérogeant à l'obligation scolarité soit
sont des assurés dans la liquidation
intervient alors qu'ils ont commencé
leur carrière avant 1959 c'est de plus
en plus rare d'une certaine manière
c'est assez statistique soit des assurés
qui l'ont fait avec un caractère très
dérogatoire et aujourd'hui ce qui
commence à travailler avant saison le
fond dans des dispositifs généralement
de préparation à l'apprentissage qui ne
sont pas assujettis à cotisation et qui
n'entre pas dans ce cadre puisque
c'était c'est assimilable des périodes
de formation donc on est dans cette
équation là elle est évidemment
compliquée et surtout elle renvoie aux
carrières et à la construction de vie de
chacun avec un impact budgétaire
particulier c'est ce que je voulais
ajouter madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le ministre
vous avez compris la préoccupation juste
un point si on met 43 ans à tout le
monde ce ne sont plus des carrières
longues ce sont des carrières normales
donc il faut trouver un dispositif à ce
moment-là de carrière précoce de
carrière précoce ne l'oubliez pas plus
vous anticipez l'âge plus vous vous
accordez une durée longue de retraite à
ces personnes là donc il faut pas rater
la cible quand je dis la cible c'est ça
c'est celui qui était quel métier
pénible moi qui je pense qui a commencé
le bonheur et celui-là il est usé quand
même au bout d'un certain nombre
d'années c'est celui-là qu'il faut
essayer de cibler et ben c'est trop
compliqué
et ben le système qui est proposé
actuellement qui se base sur la même
philosophie gomme certaines injustices
effectivement par rapport à mais ne les
gommes pas tous mais il engomme un petit
peu c'est pour ça que je demandais à
Monsieur le Ministre d'essayer de revoir
de créer un dispositif qui est en gomme
encore plus c'est nez inégalités et puis
vous dire simplement que si on part d'un
principe non pas que les 43 ans sont un
plancher mais que les 43 ans sont un
plafond pour équilibrer notre système de
retraite de par répartition déjà en
déséquilibre et qui conduit dans les
dizaines d'années qui viennent à ce que
les pensions des retraités relativement
par rapport au niveau moyen continue de
baisser
si on ne fait rien je vous le rappelle
et bien il faudrait il faudrait c'est
votre recette mais laissez-moi finir la
recette je suis en train de la mettre en
application
si on part de ce principe là pour
équilibrer le système et qui ne conduit
toujours pas à faire en sorte que les
retraités d'une pension meilleure c'est
45 ans qu'il faut comme durer de
cotisation pour tout le monde c'est 45
ans vous voyez c'est on peut faire un
raccourci mais dans le système qui est
bien complexe vous l'avez compris que le
système était complexe et bon on
n'arrive pas forcément à travers ses
propos à ce que l'on souhaite voilà
merci Monsieur Fichet
oui monsieur monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur c'est Monsieur le
Ministre moi je vous admire
tout à l'heure vous nous avez fait à peu
près 15 minutes exposé sur les départs
anticipés là là on a passé cinq six
minutes à comprendre la complexité des
carrières langues et je peux vous dire
c'est totalement incompréhensible pour
le citoyen lambda qui nous pose la
question en disant mais moi à quel
moment je pars en retraite pour ma part
je vois pas bien comment je pourrais lui
expliquer à quel moment il est dans les
cas hier longue à quel moment il a un
trimestre de plus un trimestre de moins
ou un chemise de push à cimaise de moi à
quel moment il peut être considéré dans
les départs anticipées en tous les cas
ça devient extrêmement compliqué
extrêmement difficile je salue aussi le
travail du rapporteur qu'il est dessus
fait l'objet d'une démonstration assez
parfaite de la compréhension des
mécanismes et je me dis que souvent on
parle de notre administration qui est
compliqué on dit mais je suis allé voir
l'administration d'abord c'est difficile
décédé aujourd'hui il faut prendre des
rendez-vous mais en plus il faut remplir
des dossiers et bien le dossier de
retraite des personnes qui sont
concernées par cette ce nouveau projet
de retraite là je leur souhaite vraiment
bien du plaisir mais je voudrais quand
même rappeler que pour tout ce qui
concerne globalement sur les départs
anticipés les personnes qui sont
frappées d'un handicap qui sont en
difficulté etc et invoque quand même
travailler deux années de plus et c'est
ça qui m'inquiète et je crois que cette
réforme de retraite sera marquée par ce
dispositif là en plus de l'article 7 ça
veut dire que tout d'un coup les
personnes pour qui le travail est une
chose épanouissement mais parfois aussi
un exercice difficile sur le plan
physique ou sur le plan mental qui
mérite le on va dire à 50-55 ans parce
que l'effort est double chez elle et ben
là maintenant non seulement il est pas
avancé mais il est reculé et de rentrer
deux ans de plus et ça c'est bien
difficile à expliquer une fois de plus
je vous remercie madame Pomerol
oui moi je voudrais m'adresser à
Monsieur du soft puisque vous venez
déclarer monsieur le ministre il y a
quelques instants que vous lui rassurer
madame Lubin en lui disant que ce soit
un PJL ou un pvfss j'aurais eu le même
souci de l'équilibre et c'est bien là
que le black blesse votre souci c'est
l'équilibre et en budget en matière de
budget un équilibre c'est un équilibre
entre les recettes et les dépenses et
vous vous ne privilégiez que la
diminution des dépenses vous ne voulez
pas entendre parler d'augmentation de
recettes
vous avez multiplié je ne vais pas y
revenir le dogue avec dogme de moins
d'impôts et d'exonération vous avez
multiplié les cadeaux fait au plus riche
vous ne voulez pas entendre parler de
recettes vous nous avez tout refusé
alors oui moi aussi je préfère la
justice à un problème budgétaire donc
tous ceux qui ont eu 43 ans dans l'unité
avant l'âge de 64 ans doivent partir au
bout de ces 43 ans d'unités c'est une
question de justice
on touche merci Madame Président on
touche avec
cet article
un sujet de clarté d'intelligibilité de
la loi pour nos concitoyens
il y a évidemment la question de la
justice et les exemples qui ont été
donnés par mes collègues montre à quel
point cette réforme dans l'ensemble de
ces aspects par son article 7 et sur
l'article dont on discute en ce moment
son vécus est vécu comme une réforme
injuste mais ce sujet quand même de
d'intelligibilité pour nos concitoyens
me paraît central j'ai reçu aujourd'hui
par mail comme vous tous sans doute
parce que nous sommes suivis par nos
concitoyens par les réseaux sur le
direct Public Sénat un cours mail d'une
habitante de ce Neymar elle dit je vis
dans un mot près de Louhans et je vous
contacte concernant la réforme des
retraites et plus exactement sur le
début de son application pour les
personnes nées après le premier
septembre 1961 ce qui est mon cas et qui
auront trois mois de plus à faire je
trouve plus logique et en cohérence avec
l'ensemble de la démarche que le
démarrage se fasse sur une année pleine
pourriez-vous prendre en compte dans le
cadre d'une éventuelle négociation notre
première ministre madame borne est né
sur une période de 1961 qui n'est pas
concerné par la réforme peut-être
pourra-t-elle être sensible à cette
demande alors c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres mais les gens n'y comprennent
rien la seule chose qu'ils ont compris
c'est que c'était injuste donc s'il vous
plaît est-ce qu'on peut quand même
essayer de faire en sorte que on se
prive de l'injustice de l'inutile
complexité et d'un sentiment
d'intelligibilité pour ceux qui auront à
vivre les effets de cette réforme
merci monsieur le Président rénal
merci Madame le présidente moi je
à ce point des débats sincèrement et
malgré les efforts déjà et des autres
pour expliquer je salue tout à l'heure
l'explication de notre rapporteur
mais tout de même au final
j'ai l'impression qu'on vote tout un
aveugle
explique excusez-moi un aveugle sur le
coup des mesures l'équilibre des mesures
le bilan de ces mesures je ne sais rien
et ce qui m'a rassuré c'est que le
rapporteur d'une certaine façon
j'ai déjà dit je crois hier ou
avant-hier est honnête dans sa réflexion
c'est-à-dire quand il sait pas ou quand
il se dit qu'on pourrait faire mieux il
le dit et c'est une bonne chose on n'est
pas sur de la mathématique
identifiée clair on peut pas faire des
sommations mais quand même
départ anticipé
quels sont qu'elles auraient pu être les
différentes propositions n'en sais rien
il y en a une sur la table on sait pas
exactement ce qu'elle coûte etc carrière
longue même combat on pourrait faire
mieux c'est pas très bon c'est pas très
bien ces personnes font moins coûteux
que si c'était mieux bon très bien
contraignant on nous dit 800 millions
d'euros un milliard 200 millions on ne
sait pas trop la tête nous tourne
carré en progressive ça viendra plus
tard mais pareil on aura un coup mais
est-ce que c'est le bon etc bref moi ce
que j'aurais aimé monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre c'est qu'on est un
petit tableau
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait là quoi
combien ça coûte les opérations et si on
faisait mieux combien ça coûterait et
qu'on ait un choix alors c'est le choix
sur les sucres on est bien d'accord
c'est pas le choix de la réforme la
réforme est contre mais c'est les petits
sucres pour faire passer pour faire
passer la réforme mais encore faut-il
qu'on ait un peu d'idées sur ces petits
sucres en fait ces petits sucres ils ont
été négociés ils ont été négociés dans
une salle noire et là ça apparaît mais
sans les chiffrages excusez-moi de vous
le dire
monsieur Mérillou
depuis
6 jours j'écoute attentivement tout ce
qui se dit et ça me fait penser à ce que
disait Mitterrand il y a quelques années
quand je ne serai plus là il ne restera
plus que des comptables et des
financiers
monsieur le ministre vous êtes un
comptable et en financier vous êtes
chirurgical vous êtes sans état d'âme et
vous ne mesurez plus le coût humain de
vos arbitrages vous êtes perdus dans vos
arbitrages techniques dont
personnellement je ne comprends plus
grand chose mais le côté humain vous
l'avez totalement oublié en fait vous
êtes un Robin des bois moderne mais
inversé vous prenez au pauvres pour
donner aux riches et là je reconnais que
vous avez un certain talent dans ce
domaine vous êtes efficace constant et
c'est cela que je regrette
[Musique]
que même si jamais elle n'avait pas été
dans ce projet de loi de finances
rectificatif vous auriez eu à coeur
l'équilibre de
financier pourquoi est-ce que vous ne
l'avez pas fait dans un autre dans une
autre projet de loi que celui-là ça nous
aurait permis d'avoir un peu plus de
temps mais on comprend bien pourquoi
vous l'avez fait au bout du compte
si monsieur le ministre
trois points madame la Présidente
d'abord pour dire au président rénal que
sur les différents scénarios proposés
par ces amendements j'ai donné les
chiffres et le coût la parole qui est la
mienne quand je suis devant vous pour
dire quels sont les coûts d'une mesure
proposée par les parlementaires ça puis
évidemment sur le travail de mes
services mais je n'ai pas la possibilité
et c'est plutôt heureux de modifier les
tableaux d'équilibre et l'étude d'impact
en même temps que j'annonce les coûts à
ce micro donc j'ai dit les coûts tout à
l'heure j'ai notamment dit le coup de
l'amendement des deux amendements dont
j'ai demandé le retrait à la fin de
l'allias que nous estimons autour de 300
millions d'euros mais j'essaye à chaque
fois que c'est possible et en fonction
des éléments dont je dispose de préciser
les coûts et j'essaye aussi d'avoir le
plus de clarté dans les explications que
j'essaye de donner au Sénat la deuxième
chose pour revenir sur le caractère
complexe et beaucoup d'entre vous ont à
l'instant dans les dernières
interventions dit je n'ai pas bien
compris j'ai peur de ne pas comprendre
ou finalement je ne comprends rien
oui c'est compliqué c'est extrêmement
compliqué et je tiens à dire puisque
beaucoup de sénateurs du groupe
socialiste nous ont presque fait ce
reproche de complexité que le système
des carrières longues a été créé en 2003
et que lorsque et je le répète je l'ai
voté comme vous cette loi lorsque la loi
Touraine a été votée personne ne nous a
proposé de modifier le système de
carrière longue à aucun moment ni de
créer la borne à 18 ni de créer la borne
à 21 ans ni de modifier ni modifier les
critères des éligibilité personne
personne ne nous l'a proposé et
il y avait une mesure de retour à 60 ans
pour les dispositifs de carrière longue
mais pas plus pas plus pas moins que ce
qui avait été prévu à partir de 2003
donc je disais à un moment dans une
explication peut-être un peu emporté il
y a quelques jours que parfois j'ai le
sentiment qu'on nous reproche d'avoir le
courage de nous attaquer à ce que
d'autres n'ont jamais eu le courage
d'ouvrir et c'est le cas sur les
carrières longues c'est le cas sur les
carrières longues et puis enfin
et puis enfin
et enfin je termine je termine par
Monsieur Mériot je suis bien écouté vos
propos et vos mises en cause personnelle
je pense que c'est à peu près du même
niveau du même acabit que les propos de
votre collègue qui est rouge qu'il a 48
heures ça me laisse penser que comme
beaucoup d'autres la seule chose qui
vous habite désormais c'est la
radicalité et une mélenchynisation de
l'esprit
[Applaudissements]
madame Ferret
les sorties madame Cohen
Monsieur
Madame Cohen
alors nous au niveau du groupe
communiste dans ce débat là on est hyper
à l'aise parce qu'on a pas soutenu la
réforme Touraine on s'est battu bec et
recette réformes extrêmement mauvaise
porte ouverte au suivant on s'est battu
avant contre les mesures Fillon et on se
bat aujourd'hui Monsieur le Ministre
contre votre réforme alors là je pense
qu'on peut être salué applaudit notre
constance notre combativité et le fait
qu'on ne lâche rien voilà donc c'est
mauvais ça continue d'être mauvais et
tout ce que vous nous dit depuis le
début et bien conforte conforte nos
positions les gens majoritairement vont
perdre deux ans de plus et finalement
vous restez toujours fidèle à la même
logique c'est à dire que vous ne prenez
pas l'argent là où il se trouve vous
demandez les mêmes efforts au plus petit
au plus fragile et concernant les
carrières les carrières longues puisque
c'est le sujet pour ne m'éloigner
l'Institut des politiques publiques
montrent que le système dit des
carrières longues réservées aux
personnes ayant commencé à travailler
tôt ne profite pas principalement à
celles qui sont les moins qualifiées ou
les plus abîmés abîmés par leur emploi
donc si vous voulez on voit là qu'il y a
un vrai problème mais comme vous ne
prenez pas l'argent comment vous l'a
proposé avec des recettes nouvelles et
bien vous prenez le problème à l'envers
monsieur monsieur Durand pour rappel au
règlement
de la pensée
oui madame la Présidente merci chez le
ministre je
sais la charge de travail qui est la
vache c'est l'investissement où vous
avez eu ce texte quel que soit nos
options on peut que constater que vous
vous êtes dévoué pour la cause enfin
pour le coup je crois que la fatigue et
la lassitude vous éloigne de la réalité
de ce qu'a dit notre collègue merylou à
l'instant dont on peut pas considérer
que ce soit le plus agressif des
socialistes ici présent quand on
s'adresse à vous en évoquant la
politique que vous conduisez je crois
qu'il faut vraiment pas le prendre pour
vous à titre personnel d'autant qu'il a
interpellé le ministre sur des choix
politiques donc voilà il va rester
quelques jours de débat jusqu'au
dimanche soir notre esprit n'est
évidemment pas la mise en cause
personnelle de toutes les personnes qui
se trouvent dans cette émission et en
tout cas notre collègue merylou a
développé des arguments politiques
auxquels notre groupe souscrit
remercier Monsieur le Ministre et notre
rapporteur pour les explications mais je
rejoins ce qui a dit mon collègue Fichet
c'est incompréhensible à expliquer à nos
concitoyens quand on est interrogé vous
avez inventé une espèce de fonction en
escalier sinusoïde et je vais faire un
parallèle en ce moment avec la
délégation aux entreprises et des
collègues on est en train de travailler
sur la simplification des normes moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que la réforme
que vous nous proposez elle est loin de
simplifier les choses elle est complexe
et voilà pourquoi je pense que la
proposition de même Lubin est une bonne
proposition pour simplifier les choses
merci alors monsieur thémal vous avez le
choix vous pouvez soit faire un rappel
au règlement soit intervenir dans la
discussion générale dans la despilation
de vote vous n'avez pas fait encore
très bien
vous aviez les deux options merci madame
le Président pour ce choix là je vais
prendre le premier choix c'est pour dire
à Monsieur le Ministre que nous
connaissons bien depuis des années donc
on peut se parler sincèrement et
honnêtement
nous fumes nous fume camarades et c'est
pas une insulte en même dans mes propos
chacun ensuite a droit de faire un
parcours de vie moi je ne juge pas je
veux juste lui dire que moi j'entends et
je sais son implication forte sa volonté
de faire avancer cette réforme et c'est
son droit le plus légitime mais monsieur
Miss il faut que accepter également et
je libère globalement que d'autres
parlementaires qui soient d'ailleurs
quel que soit le banc les bancs de cette
hémicycle et d'autres options d'autres
opinions et les portes tout simplement
et c'est le droit élémentaire monsieur
miriou à notre collègue il a juste dit
il nous a pas cité il a évoqué la
question de François Mitterrand je crois
que vous et moi nous avons au moins ça
en partage en héritage ce qui était
François Mitterrand sont héritage il
l'avait fait part d'une vision
potentiellement qui arriverait après ne
vous sentez pas viser donc entendez bien
monsieur le ministre que nous avons pas
la même options que vous c'est vrai que
quand vous nous dites que c'est la seule
option nous considérons qu'à d'autres
options
par exemple le capitaine n'a pas été
inclus dans cette réforme là nous
conseillons notamment que là qu'on
évoque la question des fins de carrière
nous avons des visions différentes hier
notamment sur la question des étudiants
et leur possible de racheter leur
trimestre nous avons des visions
différentes d'un emportées par Monsieur
Cardon voilà donc à ce n'est pas en cela
une insulte épiquant vous dites quand
vous demandez à juste titre vous
demandez qu'on vous respecte
vous ne pouvez pas leur répondre que y
aurait pour les autres une
mélenchonisation des esprits parce que
ça marche un sens comme dans l'autre
d'abord nous sommes ici nous sommes ici
vous le savez bien pour mon colibri ou
moi-même socialiste et non pas et les
filles donc de rentrer pas dans ce jeu
là sinon nous n'avons pas y arriver vous
demandez le respect c'est légitime
entendez à être soyez respectueux de
l'opposition qui porte des arguments et
une vision différente de la vue de vous
pardon merci et la parole est à Monsieur
où il y a
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
ministre mais mes chers collègues je
partage totalement ce que vient nous
dire le président rénal et je crois que
il y a vraiment une grosse défaillance
dans dans votre projet c'est qu'il n'y a
pas d'évaluation des conséquences de la
réforme sur la fonction publique et
notamment sur sur le déroulement des
carrières dans la fonction publique je
vais juste prendre un exemple il
concerne un domaine que je connais un
peu qui est l'enseignement supérieur et
là et la recherche il est évident de
chemin ministre qu'avec l'augmentation
de l'âge moyen vous augmentez aussi le
gvt des établissements de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche et vous
savez le monsieur le ministre que le gvt
n'est pas compensé donc vous allez
rajouter une charge financière aux
établissements de recherche et aux
établissements d'enseignement je crains
sincèrement monsieur le mise mais j'ai
pas fait d'évaluation que ça remette en
question les engagements que vous avez
pris ici même dans l'hémicycle dans le
cadre de la loi de programmation de la
recherche là-dessus on aurait aimé avoir
une analyse précise il va y avoir en
effet des grosses différences dans dans
la durée des carrières par ailleurs je
devrais pas le dire ça ici mais vous
donnez la la possibilité à certains
fonctionnaires d'aller jusqu'à 70 ans
est-ce que vous avez mesuré exactement
quel pourrait être la charge pour l'État
merci madame la présidente madame Vogel
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je voulais vous dire que si le
dispositif carrière Lang est certes je
pense y compris dans cette hémicycle
difficile à comprendre le plus
problématique c'est qu'il est surtout
très compliqué à expliquer aux
françaises aux Français qui nous
regardent et ça c'est un problème de
clarté de la loi et j'aimerais vous dire
que ce qui est important pour les
Françaises et les Français qui nous
écoutent c'est pas de savoir qui des
anciens socialistes des nouveaux
macronistes touché pas quoi ont voté ou
en pavoté la loi Touraine mon père qui a
commencé à travailler à 15 ans il s'en
fiche complètement de savoir qui a voté
la loi Touraine et est-ce que ce sont
les mêmes qui aujourd'hui sont contre la
réforme etc ce qu'il aimerait savoir
c'est à quel moment il va pouvoir partir
à la retraite et ça je crois que c'est
c'est là où on a un problème et
j'aimerais vraiment vous dire que quand
on vous pose des questions simplement
pour vous donner l'occasion aussi
d'expliquer clairement pour que les gens
qui regardent à la télé les débats au
Sénat puissent comprendre tout
simplement à quel âge ils vont pouvoir
partir à la retraite en fonction de
laquelle ils ont commencé à travailler
il vous demande pas de nous dire si on
est devenu mélenchoniste ou pas je ne
comprends pas d'ailleurs comment ce
terme peut intervenir dans un débat où
on a simplement des gens qui je crois
très calmement demande des explications
factuelles sur un dispositif complexe si
c'est ça pour vous être mélenchoniste je
crois que ça dit plus de vous que de
nous
voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors on va madame pansement je vous ai
pour un rappel au règlement d'accord
oui ben l'article 36 bis sur les propos
de Monsieur le Ministre quand même
monsieur le ministre hier monsieur
retaillot a dit exactement la même chose
vous le dites aujourd'hui bon ça montre
une certaine collusion mais ce que je
pense c'est que vous regrettez vraiment
monsieur le ministre vous regrettez
vraiment que ce que vous avez
prétendument condamné l'Assemblée
nationale ne se passe pas au Sénat et
donc vous usez de la provocation
vous regrettez vraiment
que ça soit la droite qui montre qu'elle
ne voulait pas discuter de l'article 7
choses qui n'a pas pu être démontré à
l'Assemblée nationale vous regrettez
beaucoup que une à une on va vous
dégonfler vos fameuses mesures sociales
ces mesures qui ne sont que des
atténuations qui n'y arrivent même pas
d'ailleurs pour les carrières longues
dans la brutalité de votre réforme et
puis je vous dirais monsieur le ministre
c'est un problème c'est un effet
d'optique comme dirait les médecins en
fait vous vous allez à droite monsieur
Retailleau il va à l'extrême droite
alors c'est sûr tout à fait on le verra
pour l'immigration ça le et sur les
questions sociales donc à partir de là
quand on va à droite et quand on va à
l'extrême droite il y a un effet
d'optique y compris les socialistes ils
ont des positions trop radicales et pour
vous l'arrivée qualité s'est Mélenchon
donc de choses à intervenir à terre
c'est transitif voilà mais c'est une
preuve question et cette provocation
monsieur le ministre ne l'attentez pas
trop souvent bien nous allons donc
considérer que
attendez pardon monsieur Houlgate madame
d'abord
madame madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues Claude
Reynal a dit que nous avons Sion à
l'aveugle et ça ça me fait penser à une
maxime de sagesse qui dit que quand un
aveugle guide un autre aveugle il tombe
tous les deux dans le fossé je vous
envoie je vous envoie à l'admirable
tableau de BRUGEL l'ancien sur la
parabole des aveugles ça veut dire ça
veut dire d'une certaine façon aussi ça
veut dire d'une certaine façon aussi
qu'on ne peut pas être aveugle à l'heure
actuelle à l'inquiétude l'angoisse et la
colère qu'il y a dans la rue ça veut
dire aussi que nous avons un devoir de
clarification et de clarté dans dans les
différents textes et notamment
dispositifs que nous mettons en place
alors je comprends que le dispositif
carrière longue issu de la réforme de
2003 d'une certaine façon soit devenue
par décret une usine à gaz d'où la
nécessité de revenir à quelque chose moi
qui me semble simple justement c'est 43
années me semble simple alors on a cité
l'exemple des polytechniciens et c'est
vrai ils sont pas légion les
polytechniciens puisqu'ils sont salariés
de l'État dès leur première année
d'études et bien il cotise et il
pourrait peut-être partir à la
retraite plutôt mais en général les
polytechniciens ils ont des fonctions
qui sont des fonctions responsabilités
et il reste assez longtemps dans dans
leur poste par contre on avait parlé et
ça a été évoqué à l'Assemblée nationale
de du risque de ce qu'on appelait le job
d'été alors ce job d'été des étudiants
qui auraient entre guillemets travaillés
un mois par ci un mois par là et qui
leur donnerait l'ouverture entre
guillemets à des trimestres et qui
viendrait perturber parce que c'est vrai
que les étudiants ensuite n'ont pas une
carrière pénible il faut se replacer
peut-être dans le contexte de l'époque
chrono n'est pas
[Musique]
n'est pas déclenché
pas déclenché le compteur mais n'en
profitez pas donc je vais pas en
profiter je termine justement pour dire
que la situation des étudiants a
complètement évolué et ceux qui se
penchent sur cette question savent que
désormais les jobs d'été c'est une
nécessité pour ses étudiants et c'est
aussi peut-être une des conditions de la
mixité sociale dans dans l'enseignement
dans l'enseignement supérieur donc ne
pénalisons pas ces étudiants qui d'une
certaine façon auront fait des efforts
et qui pourront peut-être parce qu'ils
auront cumulé des trimestres partir un
peu plus tôt
madame Ferret
madame la Présidente merci
sur cette réforme et sur le sujet sur
lequel nous parlons depuis quelques
moments maintenant la question des
carrières longues le journal de mon
secteur Ouest-France à titré une réforme
dure à avaler oui elle est dure à avaler
cette réforme pour celles et ceux qui
tous on va dire même qui seront
concernés demain parce que pour tous ces
deux ans de plus votre réforme c'est de
reculer l'âge de légal de départ à la
retraite de 62 à 64 ans pour tout le
monde y compris pour les carrières
longues et donc là où aujourd'hui
certains pouvaient partir à 60 ans
très intéressants cet après-midi sur le
dispositif carrière longue un dispositif
que beaucoup de sénateurs ont dénoncé
comme étant très difficile à comprendre
et c'est même le moins que l'on puisse
dire on voit que on a assez débats qui
ont également été perturbés par une
intervention du ministre du Travail on
va en parler avec alexandre Poussin
Alexandre qu'est-ce qui s'est passé tout
à l'heure dans l'hémicycle effectivement
Quentin et bien en fait la gauche
sénatoriale dénoncé la complexité de ce
dispositif carrière longue dans cette
réforme des retraites on va en parler
dans quelques instants dispositif
carrière longue qui est défendu par le
ministre du socle et donc le ministre du
socle a été un petit peu attaqué par les
différentes prises de parole des
sénateurs de gauche et en réponse à
cette gauche sénatoriale et bien le
ministre du Travail a dénoncé je cite la
mélenchonisation des esprits et des
propos de la gauche sénatoriale alors et
bien pour la petite histoire la
gauchinatoriale notamment les sénateurs
socialistes n'aiment pas beaucoup
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce sont deux lignes
politiques différentes et donc forcément
ces propos ont mis en colère les
sénateurs socialistes notamment qui
estiment que ces propos ne sont pas
nécessaires et qu'il faut garder une
forme de sérénité dans les débats à
éviter les personnelle Quentin oui on
peut le dire en tout cas sur le fond de
l'article 8 beaucoup de sénateurs et
bien on dit que c'était peu clair ce
dispositif carrière longue qu'est-ce
qu'il y a exactement dans l'article 8
Alex et bien content on va essayer de
l'expliquer alors cette article 8 il
concerne les départs anticipés à la
retraite et notamment les départs
anticipés pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt c'est le fameux
dispositif carrière longue et dans ce
dispositif et bien le gouvernement
prévoit à la base trois bornes d'âge à
partir desquels il y a des âges
différents de départ à la retraite pour
les Français qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 16 ans ils pourront
partir à 58 ans pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 16 et 18 ans
ils pourront partir à 60 ans et pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler entre
18 et 20 ans ils pourront partir à 62
ans alors vous le voyez ancien
dispositif assez complexe et beaucoup de
sénateurs dans le débat cet après-midi
on parlait d'usine à gaz écoutez le
sénateur centriste Jean-Marie
je ne pense pas que tout le monde ici
est fait Polytechnique pour comprendre
le dispositif des carrières longues que
notre ami collègue René Paul Savary
s'était vertueux à nous décortiquer mais
à vous que c'est pas simple j'ai bien
compris compte tenu effectivement qui a
plusieurs paramètres qui entrent en
ligne de compte que c'est le renvoie au
décret le soin de je dirais réussir
presque une mission impossible c'est de
maintenir une certaine équité dans ce
dispositif or ce que nous avons demandé
nous groupe santé c'est qu'on lisse un
peu le dispositif
les sénateurs sont tristes également des
sénateurs de gauche qui demandent un
dispositif carrière longue plus simple
harmoniser avec une proposition que tous
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
avant 20 ans puissent partir à la
retraite du moment qu'ils ont cotisé 43
années dans le futur la durée nécessaire
de cotisation pour pouvoir partir à la
retraite alors cette proposition la
droite sénatoriale et le gouvernement
ils sont défavorables pour des raisons
budgétaires ça coûte trop cher c'était
un peu la même proposition que le député
les républicains Aurélien Pradier dans
le débat sur la réforme des retraites à
l'Assemblée nationale en le goût en
revanche le gouvernement va faire une
concession sur ce dispositif carrière
longue avec la possibilité pour ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler entre 20 ans
et 21 ans de partir à la retraite à 63
ans c'était une annonce d'Élisabeth
borne durant le débat à l'Assemblée
nationale et ça va être traduit dans
fait normalement dans ce débat au Sénat
et bien merci merci Alexandre pour
toutes ces explications c'est la fin de
ce Grand Direct autour de l'examen de la
réforme des retraites mais dans quelques
minutes ne bougez pas édition spéciale
de sens public Thomas Hugues qui est
bien reçoit pour l'occasion le président
du Sénat Gérard lâché nous on se
retrouve demain matin à 9h30 ici depuis
la salle des conférences pour suivre
l'examen de cette réforme des retraites
très belle suite des programmes sur
Public Sénat
[Musique]
aujourd'hui quand on se promène sur le
quai du port à Marseille on voit des
immeubles des années 50 et 60
[Musique]
oui passer la ville ancienne
le quartier du port fondé par les Grecs
il y a 2600 ans vivant et populaire a
été détruit en 1943 j'ai retrouvé cette
image avec la foule qui regarde
Hitler en personne à ordonné les
opérations d'évacuation et de
destruction du quartier du Vieux-Port de
Marseille
parmi l'évacuer 12000 déplacés vers le
camp de Fréjus 800 déportés dont 200
juifs qui furent envoyés vers le camp de
la mort de Sobibor
les médias n'avaient aucun intérêt à
parler de cette histoire la raffinée
demain à 22h sur Public Sénat
[Musique]
sur les trois sons domaines skiable de
France 80 stations sont menacées de
fermeture d'ici 30 ans en raison du
réchauffement climatique on a 2000
emplois on ne peut pas laisser les gens
comme ça on se rend pas compte de la
science de l'homme sur la nature en
continuant de bétonner la montagne je
suis pas certain que l'avenir de la
montagne soit garantie la fonte de leur
blanc dimanche à 13h sur Public Sénat
[Musique]
les derniers